ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
course countdown dreary planning
committee my name is Christopher kettle
and I'm the chairman of Stratford
District Council and at this point I'm
therefore chairman of this meeting I'd
like to start off by just reminding
everybody please could you show your
mobile phones are switched off while I'm
silent and if and when you're invited to
speak please could you come forward to
one of the two empty tables in front of
you and ensure that before you begin
speaking you switch the microphone on
that you do not try and swallow the
microphone because it doesn't work to
every well just keep a little bit back
from it I'm now going to ask the
officers to reduce themselves starting
on my far right hand bands from
committee services Ross chambers legal
services adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the conduct the
code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal Town Planning Institute and
planning committee members not bound by
the case officers recommendation or by
oral advice new hemstead Senior Planner
I'll be presenting the application
Benson why she County Council senior
develop management engineer for the
Highway Authority John Kerr for the
policy manager has traffic counsel for
coming and housing John Archer where
each County Council Anthony Shapland I'm
from collies International on
undertaking the viability work on behalf
of the council thank you do we have the
apologize for this meeting me - we've
got apologies from councillors Atkinson
and Crump and also councillor Barnes is
due to be here he's already indicated
that he would sit out as Ward member but
he had an appointment this afternoon a
medical appointment they couldn't get
Hart off so he still is intending to
come
now move on to point two disclosure of
interest and dispensations mister mister
cent yes chairman I've been appointed a
member of this committee despite the
fact that I have a recorded objection
that objection was made when the
proposal was for zero affordable housing
and effectively I'm prepared to sit
under committee tonight with an open
mind and you know and treat the
application you know having been so
uncommitted before my arrival here she
mr. st. any any other issues people wish
to raise at this point in time move on
there is of course I'm just getting a
little preamble one application tonight
now there were many things members may
wish to discuss but I would just like to
say whilst I am sitting in the chair
that I find it very uncomfortable that
we should be requested to consider or
may have the request to consider certain
items confidentially when this is a
matter of such public interest and when
we have things on blue paper it does
give me a concern that we're making
decisions based on information that will
not be in the public domain which i
think is unfortunate
at which point we'll move on to point
three the appointment of chairman now
I'm not a professional planning chairman
and therefore since we have one of our
normal chairmen present I'm proposing I
should step down and invite invitations
to nominate one of my more experienced
colleagues mr. fielding
do I have a seconder for that like do we
have any other nominations in which case
I think mr. carriage and I will sort
places to continue the rest of the
meeting thank you
right thank you very much so I think we
are now item for the meat of the agenda
and if is it Neal and are you going to
give us the description of the
application okay thank you
the the application for four members is
for the submission of reserved matters
which includes access appearance
landscaping layout and scale for 400
dwellings including open space drainage
works highway works and all other
associated works pursuant to planning
permission 1403 five seven nine which is
an outline permission dated to 28 to
February 2017 straight into the yep just
for exploration the format will be as
you probably know we will hear from the
officer a description of the site as an
as we would a normal application then we
will hear from objectives and supporters
then we will have technical questions of
the officers from the panel and then we
will discuss it and make a decision more
of that later so if we go straight into
the description thank you chairman the
application site is outlined in red on
the screen and corresponds to that
approved to outline stage now to give
members just a bit more context on here
is that the the red line is is roughly
plotted on the site there so you can see
it is split between master and seeker
parish and Quintin parish
there's the Camden Road runs along the
side there the Greenway and the heart of
England way for public footpath or on
the south of the site so the the
application site is is relatively flat
and in in order to give members no view
of the site an aerial photograph is
probably the best way to give members
some context this I've got some
additional photographs which I'll show
later in in the
presentation but to give some key
reference points which which will help
to understand the sites if I go roughly
around the the red line with with that
with the cursor it's approximately
following down there through to the
Greenway into the east here you can see
the edge of of Long Marston and the and
the Greenway running south to north
there is an existing Bund on the Long
Marston site which is actually outside
the the redline map application site
before you but it's probably the best
reference point for some photographs
which I'll refer to later in the
presentation this is the main area where
the houses are to be located there's a
cops'll of trees here which I will refer
to in the presentation and southern
field here which is where sports pitches
and some allotments are going this is
the existing access to the application
site so looking at the proposal which is
to accommodate 400 Wellings
this is the proposed site layout and
just to give some point of reference
that's the the cops of tree that I was
referring to in the last slide and that
is the southern field where the sports
pictures and allotments are going so
just to give some some key features
there's a new entrant roundabout going
in there which will contain a
significant amount of open space and
there is a pedestrian link going there
the new tube and crossing the houses are
in perimeter resident residential block
configuration which I'll go into later
in the presentation there are
significant number of tree-lined streets
going through a significant amount of of
open space throughout the entire site
sports pictures and allotments which I
referred to earlier destination play
area to the north with
community orchard and as I referred to
earlier a link through to the Greenway
and just the incest is the final link
through there the affordable housing on
the site which is reference in the
committee of Poole is considered to be
satisfactorily distributed throughout
the site and just to give members an
indication where that is located it's
just where I put the cursor so it's in
that area there and throughout the site
another grouping there throughout the
area there and through there and very
there and there so you members can see
that it is distributed throughout the
site as is detailed in the committee
report the level of affordable housing
and the housing mix are a response to
the viability issues on the site which
result from identified on-site
contamination and the services
infrastructure that have to be provided
members will also note from the
committee report that the percentage of
affordable housing is also linked to
tenure through which officers have
sought a high level of social rented
housing as detailed in the committee
report so just to perhaps give a clearer
impression of the site this is the the
landscape master plan so this really is
to illustrate the amount of open space
which is on the site which totals
approximately 21 hectares in total
probably what shows up better on this
color plan is the is the extent of the
tree line tree-lined streets which will
more than compensate for the loss of any
trees on the site at the moment and the
significant amount of open space which
permeates throughout throughout the
application sites and I've got some more
details in respect of specific elements
at the site later on in the in the
presentation
so members will refer to remember the
the Bund the ayah that I referred to in
the aerial photographs so this is a
photograph taken from the top of that
bond so just to give a reference point
this is the the cops of trees that I
referred to so the housing would be
going approximately across this area
here you can see the approximate
location of the entrance onto the Camden
Road there and me on Hill in the in the
background and the approximate location
of the southern edge of the site the top
line is a photograph that I took from
the top of the Bund and this is the one
that the applicant submitted within the
design and access statement
I've only included both of them because
I think the bottom one might appear
lighter on the screen and easier to
interpret but effectively they're the
same view so just give members of flavor
of the existing access onto site
existing T axis which is t-junction
access which is which is there your
members will be aware of reference to
works to a lay-by
which is just up up to the north there
and there are some existing accesses
such as the field access there the
impact of which both have all been
assessed from the from the new round bat
which is going which is proposed so this
is looking southward so this is the
existing access in there with the other
access directly opposite which I which I
refer to so in terms of looking at
specific aspects of the of the
application so this in more detail is
the gateway entrance which consists of a
of a new roundabout with a significant
amount of Associated open space members
will notice that the roundabout will be
softened by extensive landscaping and
some sculpting of land cross-sections
which are shown at the bottom there
there is proposed to be some some public
art which will add some visual interest
as well and
that that is something that will be
conditioned for for later the details of
which so as I mentioned earlier that the
entrance round bar has taken into
account any possible conflict with
nearby vehicle entrances and some
additional offsite highway works will
have to be undertaken to the nearby
lay-by as detailed in the committee
report so the Gateway entrance which is
there will feed into the landscaping for
the for the whole of the site and this
is the landscape strategy plan which
will touch on a number of the features
I've already mentioned so we've got the
wide tree-lined streets which go through
and permeate the site and these will
create green corridors which will be
enhanced by font gardens there's a wide
green recreational corridor there which
will lead through to the to the
destination park which is a major new
part of associated play facilities and a
community orchard wildlife corridors
permeate through the site and also at
the boundaries in accordance with the
parameter and secured outline stage
sports pitches to the bottom as I
previously mentioned where where a
pavilion is also proposed subject to a
further application there are active
routes throughout the site and
allotments are also proposed down here a
number of local greens are proposed just
where the curse who are to break up the
the blocks of housing and there's a
large area of wildflower meadow to the
south of the site and as I mentioned
through those that there is a link with
association space through to the
Greenway which follows up there there
will also be a number of features such
as benches and interpretation boards
that will enhance the experience of use
in the open space and will also help
create a healthy living environment
so turning to the dwellings the scheme
responds to the design principles and
advice put forward at the outline
permission stage by providing the
perimeter residential block configured
housing which ensures that all dwellings
front onto the public realm and create
active frontages the proposed layout
provides natural surveillance of the
streets and open spaces and allows the
outer perimeter dwellings to be
orientated to be outward look into the
surrounding countryside so in terms of
the design the layout proposes to have
three character areas and if I explain
those in the first instance then I've
got some indicative street scenes that
will give some context to the overall
design so we have in the first instance
we have the rural edge character area
which you can follow with the with the
cursor there this is locating the fringe
of the scheme and comprises outward
facing development that overlooks the
prominent green open spaces properties
in this character area are largely
detached properties with curved building
lines that help create a softer edge
character materials include weather
boarding to reflect the rural character
picturesque character areas are located
towards the center of the of the scheme
and are the blue area shown on the
screen
these have a denser block blocks of
developments with a mixture of some
short terraced semi-detached and
detached properties the predominant
building material here will be will be
red brick and finally that the larger
character area will be the
arts-and-crafts character area so this
encompasses the primary access streets
it also contains the properties at front
of the green link along the western edge
boundary she's just showing here central
green corridor and those that are but
the the northwest eastern edge as well
so just giving some context in terms of
the design of those dwellings so these
are some executive Street scenes taken
from
the the application site so you can see
in terms of the design the the Arts and
Crafts style houses and also some of the
picturesque houses which are showing
there and giving context with the rural
edge and you can see some of the weather
boarding added added on there and this
is the the raw edge the entrance which
will be just to just see it on there
just by the the Gateway area which I
referred to earlier and again some
examples of the picturesque the housing
the hall will be part of picturesque
character area details such as external
materials doors windows and virgin eaves
details are to be controlled by the
imposition of of conditions so
elevations shown the relatively modest
apartment blocks I've got two there two
of those to show you these are the six
by one-bedroom units and the six times
two-bedroom units as well so that's just
an example of the the apartment blocks
which will be on the site so looking at
some of the of the features which I've
which I've referred to as I mentioned
the destination play area that will be
usable usable by all wage groups now
just off the plan here this this will be
supplemented by it by kickabout area and
a mugger which is a multi-use games area
and a community orchard also in addition
to this there's also there's also
proposed to be a number of trim trails
around the site to again help promote a
healthy living environment so in terms
of the sports pitches to the to the
south of the site these areas can
accommodate either rugby or football
pitches members will note that a
condition has been imposed in order to
ensure that the pictures are provided to
the correct standard and in an agreed
time scale following discussions with
Sport England
members also know in the committee of
all reference to a sports pavilion and
it has been agreed that sports building
will provide is subject to a separate
planning application being granted to
this effect the submitted plan show
where the pavilion can be accommodated
on site and indicative plans for the
pavilion have been submitted which are
on the screen at present the part the
car park shown on the plans will be
provided to provide parking footage for
speeches and the allotments with the
land where the sports pavilion is shown
located proposed to be located being
retained as open space pending a
separate planning application being
granted before the pavilion so members
will also be aware from the committee
report that details have been provided
of the community and employment hub now
as mentioned in the committee fault this
is separate this is subject to a
separate reserved matters planning
application but indicative details have
been provided so they so they can be
seen in the context of fixing the layout
for the 400 housing so what this shows
are is the indicative layout for the for
the employment and community hub and how
it could look I stress this is this is
just draft and would be subject to a
separate reserved matters application
but some of the features it contains is
office accommodation add a nursery a d1
news building which could be a community
building and a local convenience store
so that's just an example of some of the
facilities that could be that could be
provided and just to give an example of
how this could look visually or proposed
approach at the moment the thought
process is having a look so they're more
of they have the appearance more of an
agricultural selection of agricultural
buildings which reflects the rural
character of the area
so members will also be aware of the
reference to the phasing the plan which
is which is in the in the committee of
all now condition 30 of the outline
application requires a submission of a
phasing strategy with the reserved
matters application and this has been
submitted and that the phasing plan is
is shown on the screen and the District
Council is liaison closely with the
applicant in respect to this now at the
time committee good progress has been
made that there are some outstanding
issues primarily in respect of of
triggers for the certain phases that
needs to be finalized and and hence the
recommendation before members tonight
that makes reference to the requirement
to finalize the phasing plan before
permission is granted should member
support the recommendation before them
so finally as members are aware although
this is a standalone application if
granted it may form the first phase of
the overall long while stangard and
village of 3500 now this is the this is
the master plan which has been submitted
for the 3100 application so this is
following here the blue line that's the
current reserved matters application
site with the remainder is the subject
of the 3100 application so members will
see that the the layout of the reserved
matters application before them has been
specifically designed to be part of the
first phase and fit in if this is if
this is granted and the legal agreement
is proposed to ensure that this
development will be able to integrate in
the overall garden village development
as the first phase without the formation
of grandson strips so chairman there are
a number of updates as detailed in the
committee update sheet including a
number of clarifications in respect of
the committee report is therefore
recommended that the application be
granted subject to one finalizing a
phasing strategy including an overall
phasing plan
in accordance with the requirements of
condition 30 phasing and 18 program
having implementation of open space
equipped place base of our outline
application 14 0 3 5 7 9 out and to the
completion of a legal agreements
securing one the level and tenure
affordable housing to be provided
on-site to cross boundary integration
between the application site and the
wider proposed LM a site and three
changes to the section 106 related to
the outline planning permission as a
result of the agreed phasing strategy
including the payment triggers for
education contributions for any specific
phases and the conditions and those
detailed in the committee report the
full wording of which is delegated to
officers Thank You chairman thank you
very much there's a lot there we've had
a very comprehensive presentation there
which I think complements a very
comprehensive report which I'm sure
we've all read we've all had the
opportunity to talk to officers about
this before this evening
has everyone read the update sheet
because there are some some good points
there from the parish council and
councillor house do you want a few
minutes to read that no no yes okay just
a couple of minutes
thank you so we will now hear from
objectors we have two objects of tonight
they will have three minutes each
we will then hear from the applicants
and supporters who will have six minutes
altogether will then hear from the
respective counselors counselor Barnes
and counselor brain if counselor Barnes
gets here which I hope he does so if we
start with counsel come together by all
means if you want yes so counter the
Moores of this parish so to speak and
counselor John Warrender chairman of
Ludington Parish Council if we start you
have six minutes between you you know
that we just tell you when that is yes
okay
noted so chairman like many others I'm
not happy with housing mixing I hope you
will reject this application however if
you are could I remind the committee of
the council's view on affordable housing
on 4th of May in a leaders decision and
so st. this capsule are responding to a
government consultation on the revised
national planning policy framework and
stated in connection with this and I'll
quote SPC is supportive of the review of
the clawback mechanism and considers
that it should be mandatory for
developments that are very large-scale
multi-phased or significantly slow to
deliver Sherman I couldn't come up with
a better description
this development than multi-phased now
that's July council meeting in answer to
a question the portfolio colder cancel
at Pemberton slated and again I quote
canceled at Kempton advised that
clawback agreements would be applied
thousand when appropriate German I
cannot think of a more appropriate
example with this we have a viability
assessment that's been accepted as I
understand it since it's clear clearly
this councils policy to use clawback
clauses were appropriate
could I ask the committee to add a
condition that should find all profits
exceed those in the viability assessment
then this council should be entitled to
receive a share of the profits
Thank You Georgia here both of you
together before we ask questions well
let's have questions as we go by then so
are there any questions for counts or a
Morse councillor kettle councillor boss
would have heard me say on previous
occasions that studies are fraught with
difficulty that doesn't necessarily mean
they shouldn't be introduced if
appropriate those comes to Morse have
any suggestions as to how that viability
study I sorta clawback arrangement
should be calculated in terms of the
return to the district council event the
profits are superseded and how would it
be audited I do accept test profits can
vary according to the constants cost can
be well below 13 and sales managers can
be much higher than predicted especially
with help to buy so I do think there's
difficulty around realistically
forecasting on a long-term scheme like
this what the profits would be my view
is that if they make excess profits this
council should take a [ __ ] now I'm not
going to try to
committee or officers but it clearly
have to be shared if all profits were to
come to the council there is no
incentive then for the developer to get
to maximize prices make the maximum
profit so clearly it would have to be
shared between 5050 or whatever I would
suggest is that two offices okay this
thing is I'm quite sure that in the
books of Karla homes they will maintain
this estate as a separate accounting
entity and it should be easy therefore
to arrange for audit requirements
completed to work on an open-book basis
that can be audited to come up with
reliable figures of the eventual actual
profit great thank you okay I know any
other questions
No thank you very much so we'll go to
our next speaker
Leah mr. chairman councillors just to
say that we were only set here to save
time I have no connection with capsule
Morse it's not my agenda okay so yeah so
obviously I'm chair of Ludington parish
council and our point of view basically
is that letting the parish council is
objecting to the application for 400
homes on Long Marston air field due to
the prospect of accepting only half of
the affordable housing required by the
score strategy CS 18 we're concerned
this would lead to a precedent being set
for other developers in the area and
this is bearing in mind that the future
development concerns in our village of
the old Defra site and other reserved
sites is foremost in our mind the core
strategy states that 35% is required
unless credible evidence of viability
indicates otherwise
Collier's who I believe are represented
here tonight has stated that a minimum
of 20% is viable yet we are here tonight
discussing 17.5% offered by the a
developer who's 2017 annual report
states that profits in the Midlands
with sixty eight point five million
pounds and that the company has a clear
focus on value for shareholders margin
delivery and equity and equity rich and
financially resilient customers also in
that report they're bragging that at
four hundred and ninety seven thousand
pounds their homes have the highest
private average selling price outside
London it is clear to us that this
developer does not want to build
affordable homes and therefore to accept
seventeen half percent would be an
affront to the younger generation of
hard-working Stratfor Tian's Karla homes
have been involved with the LMA site for
some years now and would or should have
been well aware of the SCI clearance
requirements due to the past uses of the
airfield already having thirteen million
from the Homes and Communities agency
this is not a developer who should be
subsidized any further the whole LM a
garden village an associated
infrastructure there's been a sticking
plaster on the district's health housing
leads from the outset the housing needs
of Stratford ian's has been ignored
along with the infrastructure of the
rural roads over a thousand objections
have been lodged against the Southwest
relief Road recently and surely this is
time now to review this whole project
our note tonight that in the
presentation elements of the 3,100
houses have been shoved into this
presentation tonight and we also believe
that these applications should be
separated and judged on their own merits
thank you okay thank you very much
council Warrender any questions no thank
you thank you candy if you can press the
bottom so goes off great we now are
going to hear from the applicants and
supporters I don't know how you want to
come forward I have mr. Jonathan
Thompson who's agent for the landowners
and John Deakin is it
it's John Deakin and you are with Karla
ok Duke Duke you might as well all come
up and and be prepared to answer
questions when and if so you've got six
minutes between you how'd you want to
separate that and then we'll have
questions at the end
Jordan if that's okay with you that's
absolutely fine do you want to know when
three minutes is up or anything like
you're gonna do that
okay great when you're ready okay good
evening members my name is Jonathan
Thompson and I'm the land agent
representing the owners of Long Marston
airfield I've been involved with this
project since it began in 2013 and I
thought be useful to explain the
background of the site as a believer
this would be an important factor when
considering tonight's application an
outline application for 400 dwellings as
a standalone scheme was submitted to the
council at the end of 2014
the planning application was governed by
policies of that time the whole airfield
was then considered by this council for
inclusion within its core strategy
during the latter part of 2015 as a new
settlement that could deliver up to
three and a half thousand new dwellings
2,000 of which will be delivered within
the core strategy period the core
strategy was adopted by this council in
2016 during this time the site was
formally selected by government in early
2016 and designated as such as a garden
village why this timeline is of
importance is because the site's
expectations and requirements have
changed from when the site was
originally submitted in 2014 the net
effect of this process was to
significantly increase the
infrastructure burden that the site went
down after the shoulder as a result of
in not being a standalone scheme 400
Wellings but a phase one of a new
settlement of Garden Village the
original application had to be in effect
retrofitted back into the plans for the
larger settlement the supermoon officer
have said the total sire is 43 hectares
and 48 percent of that area will be
public open space the reasoning for this
is to ensure the site dates to God and
religion principles delivered within the
48 percent open space will be a new
sports pavilion located immediately next
to the sports pictures allotments a
community orchard trim trails and a new
destination play area will all be
delivered as part of a comprehensive
package to help promote a happy healthy
living agenda the developer also linked
into the National Cycle Network
so enjoy ensure the site is laid out as
a first phase of a new settlement the
proposed purpose-built roundabout an
Associated gateway park will need to be
constructed and delivered at the start
of the development as opposed to
utilizing the existing right-hand turn
lane this expenditure increases upfront
costs all of the roads and sewers will
be constructed on phase one - they have
been designed to have a capacity for
three and a half thousand dwellings not
just four hundred service provision for
example gas and electric for the first
phase has been upscaled and the capacity
increased to ensure that a whole new
settlement can be delivered again this
has an impact on current cost high
quality design is a key feature of new
Garden villages this quite rightly
encompasses numerous aspects of the
scheme from tree-lined spine roads right
through to the quality of the materials
that are utilized in the proposed
dwellings but they do carry an increased
cost the outline section 186 package of
3.2 million pounds that was agreed will
be fully delivered as will the highway
improvements on the B four six three two
it is important to note that homes in
that have also been involved in this
project for over 18 months and they are
aware that the viability challenges of
the site phases Tunis and Homs England
have agreed in principle to provide a
thirteen point four million pound grant
hon David Thank You chair for the
opportunity of Karla to address your
committee its Planning Manager I deal
with plain matters for the division
accompany me to answer questions is our
managing director Mark Wright or Lam
director Dan Forester and our project
director for the site Rob McDonald
they along with myself will be able to
answer any questions that you should
have my presentation structures as
follows I give some background and then
I discuss SOI design principles the site
issues and policy requirements and
commute engagements in conclusion this
way of background this site forms a
first phase for the garden village
outline permission was issued in
February 2017 which included 50
conditions and a substantial section 106
agreement on design principles from the
outline these include generous levels of
open space nearly half of the site is
proposed as open space good design the
residential parcels include three
specific character areas materials and
detailing we will provide high quality
high quality materials and detailing and
design in terms of green infrastructure
and drainage green links and drainage
infrastructure will be functional
attractive and a real benefit for local
wildlife on site-specific issues and
policy requirements housing affordable
housing and housing mix are clearly key
issues for this application first your
affordable housing the outline section
106 specifically acknowledge that the
35% affordable housing target would be
subjective viability considerations
provisions for an alternative
arrangements plan aap reflects this in
line with core strategy policy CS 18 on
affordable housing the AAP and the
accompanying assessment form form parts
of reserve matter submission the
assessment has been independently
assessed by the council's consultants
significance site development costs
affecting viability include
contamination major highway works major
utility upgrade works or the costs
including section 106 the open space
provision itself and associated projects
with that site the original application
did not comprise affordable housing but
is now at a level of seventeen and a
half percent following the announcement
of homes England grant funding and
detailed negotiations with your officers
secondly on housing mix the housing is
mainly her family housing which actually
assists the overall level of affordable
housing that can be provided that's
verified by your independent consultants
the housing mix policy itself CS 19
provides for site-specific circumstances
to be taken into account
on agreeing acceptable mix in terms of
community engagement statements of
community engagement accompanies the
reserved matters submission showing the
extensive level of public engagement
that we've undertaken unser conclude a
fuller understanding of the cost of
developing this part of the overall
garden village has now been reached and
acknowledged by independent consultants
of a District Council and Holmes England
grant funding by Holmes England and
Carlos determination to provide delivery
of this [ __ ] this first phase would
ensure that the vision for this site is
realized with a sock with a site start
anticipated next summer following
conditioning clearances and County
Council approvals Thank You chair thank
you very much now we're going to have
questions I'll start I may be asked to
stop by our legal team I don't know and
you answer or don't answer if you think
it might be confidential and sensitive
and that kind of thing should I give
some guidance on that in terms of
affordable housing viability that has
dealt with in the public report in
headline terms so that's a absolutely
fine to discuss and ask questions on
that in the blue papers the confidential
report there's some there's some
commercially sensitive information in
terms of construction costs and sight
acquisition costs so I think specific
questions around those areas we should
go into closed session for but otherwise
I think it's fine okay it's good well it
gives us quite a lot of leeway I think
actually I will start and it's a great
application it looks lovely there's so
many good things about it I think you
know the obvious difficulty everybody
has with it is is one the housing mix
with the slant towards four and five
bedroom houses which is totally out of
our our policy and I know why you've
done that for
of affordability reasons and and because
it's the first phase and all that but
the main thing is the the affordable
element and how low it is and you you've
given very obvious and clear reasons why
it's not affordable now I understand
that but what I don't understand is why
we cannot impose a clawback mechanism as
so many people have suggested or do you
have an answer to why you don't wish to
make up the percentage in the 3100 if
they come forward I think as a starting
point 400 is a entirely separate
application and we'll come forward as an
entirely separate point I'm sorry to
interrupt I don't normally do this but
it's it's mentioned in the report you
mentioned in your your your talk that
this PHA is the costs of this phase of
this stand-alone application are so high
because they incorporate a lot of things
about the overall 3,500 so I find it
difficult to think of it and know we
have to judge this as a standalone but
the arguments for how much it costs are
being I use that it is part of the wider
scheme so this is where I'm coming from
I think it's fair to say that the
outline application for the 3100 and the
reserve maths applications that follow
that will in all likelihood be subject
to their own assessment on viability and
obviously they will get the benefit of
the works we've put in as part of this
400 application so whilst a clawback
isn't necessarily part of this picture
you will get the benefit in the future
phases by the works we're doing as part
of this phase I understand I understand
that yes the viability will be better
for phase 2 because you've done a lot of
the work here
it doesn't really stop and oh perhaps an
overall clause
for the 3500 in total I can understand
perhaps why you would argue you can't do
a clawback for the 400 because that will
that will affect the viability of the
next phase but you could have a clawback
on the entire 3,500 I would suggest us
for your committee to consider when when
the 3000 won okay first of all Chris st.
yes chairman
now I was a bit surprised when Jonathan
Thompson inferred in my view that
effectively the original application the
400 could be considered in isolation
from anything else because as he knows
and I know as we both had different
roles at the time than we have tonight
we do need a question I know but I'm
just setting the scene so I'm going to
ask him to effectively pull back from
this argument that effectively the 400
home application could be so totally
detached from the larger application
because although it wasn't included in
the core strategy at the time certainly
when it was put forward it was
considered there was something that
could feasibly be dealt with as a
standalone application
so I'm asking various comments on the
new context that I'm describing okay
thank you thank you for that question
what I hope I made clear in my speech
was that when the scheme was submitted
in 2014 it was on the basis of a
standalone scheme it was not put forward
it was not designed on the basis of
being a larger new settlement and it was
not certainly designed on the basis of
being a garden village because at that
stage there was no call strategy adopted
policy that talked about LMA as a new
settlement and there was certainly no
Gordon Village status of that born okay
we have a difference of opinion I'll
come back to you later Chris but I'm
going to go to councillor kettle yes
thank you
[Music]
we mentioned in your first presentation
that the investment at this stage was
going to benefit both this phase and any
subsequent application relation thirty
thirty one hundred might come through
there for the four hundred houses is
carrying a burden which does not relate
to its own development it carried the
burden of that actually belonged to any
subsequent application that might or
might not happen therefore the this
application the returns are being
suppressed by that extraordinary burden
that does not belong to this development
it belongs to three thousand one hundred
and I am an accountant and therefore I
do look at these things and haven't do
these things ever many years my
professional life the normal procedure
in that whilst of works may physically
be taken place at the same time that the
cost allocation will be split between
the two separate developments and
therefore why have you not considered
that as an appropriate way to go forward
because there is a knock-on effect these
profits are suppressed and used to push
down the affordable housing commitment
there will not be a compensating uplift
sorry you don't carry on a conversation
right
the subsequent application if it was to
come through the 3100 there is there
would be a sort of reversing that
actually the thirty five percent limit
should be removed because those
extraordinary costs that have been
picked up that Iran aren't there and
therefore those profits going to be
artificially higher and therefore we
should get more than thirty five percent
is that a reasonable order I think
there's probably two parts of the answer
I put food on that
one is with regards to the hip funding
that's been discussed previously one of
the possible items that Holmes England
have mentioned is they may impose a
clawback themselves on funding so they
will be essentially first charged
against the 400 for any clawback that
will come from the site given the
funding they're putting forward the
second part from a karla perspective
mark made as our managing director may
be able to finesse further but they are
essentially one there's two very
different jobs within Carla the 3100 as
you may know is run by Carla group the
400 unit allocation is run within the
Midlands division and the county fool
okay I think Canada well it certainly is
a response to some of it will maybe come
back to it but I'm going to run through
because we've got a lot of questions and
some of them might answer each other
counts of fielding my question is more
on the design can we go back to the
image that shows the three to the whole
site when developed
that's the that's the proposed site
layout as we are discussing today yes
there is one that shows the larger site
see when you've the master plan yes
you're saying that there is going to be
a community orchard where would that be
once the master plan comes about is it
so counselor this is questions to the
yes it is a question to that because I'm
concerned about where the allotments are
I believe that the allotment should be
allocated elsewhere because they it they
could be the playing field should be
expanded and allowed to be expanded for
other sport the disposition of the users
in the open space and open space uses
they've come about through extensive
negotiate well discussions that we've
had with with your offices over the last
year and obviously you know sports
England have commented on them as well
in terms of consultation responses we've
not had I don't believe any sort of
consultation response that sort of is
unhappy with with with those disposition
of uses and where we've put the
allotment simulation to the sports
pitches and so on okay I think that's
that's a clear answer and we're going to
move on if we need another shot at it we
can go back to it
counter to Perry thank you good evening
gentlemen Garden villages were first
announced the locations and I believe
LMA is one of the first of the 14 sites
that were announced very early January
2017 which obviously followed as you so
rightly said the call strategy which was
adopted in July 2016 so obviously we we
were not aware of this new go up Garden
village status that the government has
been encouraging
and all your application and plants were
done well before LMA was determined as
having this garden village status which
is and there are 14 I've got two
questions is Carla involved with any of
the other 14 garden villages and B in
percentage terms what are the sort of
increased level of costs between a
garden village site which is new
territory after all for all developers
in the UK because of standards put upon
them on from government I think I would
find it helpful to know that if you
compare this sort of type of development
compared to shall we say and your
standard 400 site development the
additional costs in percentage terms
because I don't want to go there but it
would be I think helpful because a
garden village site by its nature is
bound to be different and obviously it's
got different criteria I'm all alone to
that effect if I make firstly Carla have
no interest in any of your the garden
villages so that's the first one the
second one is more difficult to answer
and I think he's almost impossible the
garden villages are around the country
are in different places somewhere in
Greenfield some are on reclaimed land
some are going to need motorway
junctions so it's trying to ascertain a
percentage of increased cost is very
very difficult if not impossible because
of the the various requirements in terms
of the size the massing and also the
amount of infrastructure that's required
as I say bridges over motorways or large
bridges are increasingly difficult and
expensive okay so could I just add one
point to the answer and a visual
demonstration would be allow how green
it is a ordinary site the 400 units
would not have 21 hectares of open space
and the cost of putting that in in
addition the
amount of trees is in my experience
uncommon for a site of 400 units and so
what you may not be able to give you a
percentage term a visual interpretation
may be helpful
yep sorry Kara I'm going to move on you
can come back I've put you on the list
kara Cargill thank you
let's park the 17 5.5% affordable homes
for a moment of that percentage I
noticed that and I'm a little bit
confused because the the officers report
and the the colleagues reports are
slightly confusing so I appreciate if
you can others off the of the 75% we're
looking I believe at a 50-50 ten-year
split of 30% social rented and 50%
intermediate as are the shared ownership
or discounted sales now obviously we
look for the 60% as a compliant target
for social rented which is high in
demand in our district why aren't we
actually balancing it given the fact
that we are looking at 17 half percent
as opposed to the 35 percent normal and
why are we going for a higher
intermediate share of ownership and I
say or discounted because even though 80
percent of open open market it's not an
affordable home necessarily given me the
value of 370 or
odd thousand pounds for top houses okay
and answering that in part or in part
the timeline point and how the Colliers
report contradicts some of the points in
the committee report I think it's fair
to say we submitted our evidence based
colleagues reported back on that at that
stage Carla were ready to submit a
further rebuttal and go through a
further process I think it's fair to say
both Karl and officers felt that would
be a significantly prolonged process and
so a negotiation the discussion was had
after that report as opposed to going
through further evidence-based
discussions
in terms of the tenure split and we did
a range of scenario planning za nothing
the district council did the same
looking at different tenure split
positions that was the tenure split that
enabled the most amount of affordable
that was commercially viable for Cola
and I appreciate the council may have a
different view on that but that was
essentially how we could get to
seventeen and a half percent as opposed
to 16 percent or 15 percent where we may
have needed a greater proportion of
intermediate product compared to social
rent in terms of the shared ownership or
discounted sale and as an intermediate
karla have no strong preference which is
delivered for us it is about the
flexibility of tenure within the
intermediate so should a Housing
Association not be forthcoming to take
the shared ownership and there has been
evidence of that within the Midlands
region in the last 24 months that we can
assure the shared ownership or the
intermediate product is delivered and we
will cascade that then to discounted
sale so it is delivered directly the
other point I would add on discounted
sale compared to share the ownership of
a shared ownership product you pay your
mortgage and you went to the Housing
Association the discounted so you just
pay your mortgage it's brought directly
off Carla in accordance with Stratford
districts signing off who buys it how
much for whether though an affordable
need and so there is a potential saving
in the you not paying the additional
rent the security of the discount is
held on the title by the district
council to ensure that him but stays
affordable in perpetuity thank you and
yes so we're going to go around again
councillor st. councilor Ketola
counselor filled in councillor Perry so
we'll start with kind of a saint yes
Thank You chairman I'm going back to
this business of the the suggestion that
the 400 housing outline application was
put forward in 2014 as an isolated
scheme and effectively I'm going to
avoid the speakers
to deny that that was the case that
that's my question and I've but just to
set the scene if I may okay said the
question is well I haven't finished it
okay right I must bring bring issues
here because we were told tonight that
effectively in 2014 an outline
application for four hundred thousand
spot forward in the absence of a lot of
other information
now I'll concede the point that we
weren't aware of the Garden Village
issue at the time but in October 2013
this council had a visit from the
Planning Inspectorate but effectively
suggested that our core strategy
preparations were insufficient and what
we had at that particular time was a
proposal for one new settlement and we
entered a phase of work therefore in
October 2013 which had a competition for
five sites and a public consultation on
five sites and effectively the wider LM
a long asked an air-filled site was one
of those five so the scene is set so
therefore the scene is set therefore I'm
saying that the the 400 homes was then
linked to this wider application at that
time therefore I want some clarity that
effectively the committee understands
that point and there's no friggin
speaker a response to that
just just building on what I said
earlier on at the time of the submission
and from my recollection the council had
selected GLH as their preferred new
settlement there was only one new
settlement that was being proposed
within the call strategy that's what was
accepted and was on the table at the
time therefore the scheme of 400 that we
put forward was not in that basis okay I
think just I know I yeah there may have
been talks but nothing had been
finalized okay
we will have to disagree on that one the
counselor kettle again thank you you
mentioned when you responded earlier on
this point of clarification on your
response that the two developments were
entirely separate in terms of how you're
accounting but would both companies be
owned within the overall holding company
of color group which i think is now
currently owned by yes that's the case
so it is all one entity albeit split
between various different accounting
bodies legal legal entities at a lower
level when they consolidated the rules
and results we have an idea of where
we're going with this
I just wanted to establish whether the
two entities mentioned were completely
separate but actually what the answer
has just demonstrated is they all are
part of the same legal group will be
within separate entities within that
group is there a supplementary question
yes there is a second there is a second
question actually and that is within
your most recent press release the
average about your performance for 2018
average house price sale was four
hundred four hundred sixty three
thousand and last year was falling for
ninety seven thousand without are you
comfortable with those figures yes I am
but but great could I could I just
clarify as do the the average selling
price of the collar group is based on
the collar group we have four regions in
the South of England which which do
inflate that as an average the average
selling price across my business in the
Midlands is near a three hundred and
thirty thousand EPS they used for
Question and Answer Thank You councillor
Perry
Thank You chair um actually councillor
Cargill basically stole my thunder on
the affordable housing issue but I would
just like to ask one particular question
that really relates
to the discounted houses in the event
they're not taken up by the shared
ownership side it is my understanding
that a high proportion of shared
ownership properties are leasehold if
the properties went down the discounted
route if they were houses would they
become totally free home yes they are
all freehold and sometime in the future
I mean that that's that side side that's
not included as open space it's
essentially an area that's for the time
being will be fenced off but it will at
some point in the future be subsumed
into the larger side that's not within
the the 21 hectares ok and cancel cargo
thank you elements to this I hope they
can answer I'm sure we can first of all
obviously this is a garden village a
sustainable community I haven't seen
reference and I may just simply missed
it too solar panels etc but also one
other thing I'm not is 10% electric
vehicle charging points I'm asking
question why only that and also could
you just clarify the percentage of green
open space for this village I'll answer
so frankly question my problem the
project director in terms of the PV
question essentially will be going with
a fabric first approach rather than
evening essentially there's no PV the
other question regarding charge him and
the infrastructure in terms of delivery
of charging is quite contentious at the
moment in terms of what
the distributes and network operators
are coming back with so the moment they
can't provide any diversification on the
loads so they're actually saying that if
you were to go and provide charging for
housing
you'd have to allow for a full charging
we've full full capacity although which
essentially increases the infrastructure
cost for both on-site and off-site we've
that in mind the 10% provision that we
provide is sufficient for the scheme in
terms of the one thing I would note is
that it doesn't stop a free pin charge
the condition with the counts and what
we've been offered is for fast charging
which is 7.2 kilowatts so a free pin
charge could still be adapted and still
we used in our houses on the open space
to clarify it's 48 percent and just two
members may or may not understand what
fabric first means it's a developer or
term essentially that means we insulate
the houses to the point of them hitting
certain sustainability credentials that
is in use on our site and ships
announced our within the district and
that's been accepted by the district
thank you and cash turkette off your
comments you said that in the event that
there was a wider spread of charging
points that would increase
infrastructures because is that a unique
increase relating to this site and
therefore extraordinary to NMA or is it
a general comment about any development
today which I think we need to under
separate exceptional costs and standard
costs so absolutely it's it's a general
that's coming across our sites at the
moment so we've move recently sir sites
and soulful priors and they've
implemented the same so essentially the
first scheme that we looked at was an LV
supply charging points were imposed in
terms of fast charging we now haven't
support a substation on that song it's
standard across it okay thank you
that's it's been very comprehensive I
don't think there any more questions
thank you thank you very much
and we will now hear from the ward
members councillor Barnes for Welford on
Aven and councillor brain for Quinton I
think I've got that right yes counselor
Barnes is here he can come in he's
coming okay okay so we're going to have
cancer brain five minutes first just to
make it clear I am the District Council
Oh Quinton and I am the County Council
for the rest of the site which
encompasses long last and welford
Ludington and Clifford James's chairman
councilors in principle I support the
application which already as a benefit
event on planning consent that has been
assessed by planning officers
consultants and statutory concert tees
intend to meet acceptability for
approval but there's always a but my
concerns are well documented with regard
to the be four six three two which was
one of the worst road traffic apps and
records in the county in the last three
years I've been 26 injury road traffic
accidents resulting in six serious
injuries and 32 slight injuries that's
not taken into account damage only
accident a total of 38 injuries in total
several locations have been earmarked
for improvements especially at Clifford
mill where the majority of road traffic
collisions have occurred the road has
seen a significant increase in vehicle
movements already with several hundred
new had already built that the nearby
main bow which causes significant audits
during peak times causing driver
frustration which is
recipe for more road traffic collisions
therefore I believe that this road these
road improvements should be commenced
before we build any further houses
although I welcome the new traffic
island at the entrance to the site
I know fellow councils and publish
councils have shown their concerns with
regard to affordable housing which
should be in accordance with policy cs
18 of the core strategy at 35% but here
tonight were asked to agree 17 and a
half percent mainly due to viability
costs on the site are meant to several
million pounds returned to England have
accepted the challenges that the side
faces and of allocated thirteen point
five four million pounds of taxpayers
money to assist with this cancellous you
have to decide taking everything into a
consideration if this is acceptable the
house emits CS 19 of the court strategy
is not ideal that should be more
balanced with less four or five bedroom
dwellings the more smaller units again
you have to decide that this is
acceptable with the information you have
in front of you chairman with the
correct conditions and notes in place I
see no reason for refusal and unless
this committee decides that the
affordable element the mix and the road
improvements are not acceptable for
approval thank you Thank You councillor
I hope we will get clarification and
some good news about the Clifford
chambers later on are there any
questions carefully st. yes chairman
counts the brain referred to Clifford
mill in his highways communist I would
like him to perhaps clarify for the
committee the position of Clifton mill
compared to say the new roundabout
entrance to this site that we've been
told about this evening by mr. Hempstead
in his presentation I yeah i proud I'd
like to add to that question something I
didn't mean to us just to specifically
well exactly your concerns are on that
road it's the first pair of snowshoes
well documented it is thank you
I think 26 after there's been 16 at that
location
great counselor fielding my question is
can we have an image of it is there
anything on slide that we can see where
that is hopefully we'll get one up it's
it's located two to three miles north of
the site so we don't know any drawing
any maps of that but I could get it up
on Google Maps perhaps if that would
help and we can talk about it and we
will technical questions have another
chance to do if that's ok all done thank
you very much Thank You councillor cash
the bombs this site came 400 2013 we
spoke for two hours on the road to be
462 no mention the houses the inspector
at the core strategy suggested like
other sites that this site 400 come back
again because there was no problem with
the entrance and it came back and we had
another meeting mark I think came to the
first and not to the other another two
hours on the road in the process of
doing the road situation Clifford Mill
the County Council and Carla came up to
a scheme which we in the parish council
didn't agree with we got the police
involved and the police and the
environmental agency and they said what
they wanted and we still after 9 months
10 months still hadn't had a drawing the
people at the mill have to take out
life-saving they've had to take out a
course to save people's lives and and
direct their traffic on this road this
is where it's moving
because after time it's solid but the
point really is that's the position mr.
Tilford new in the respect of the site
you see my comments really as far as I'm
concerned
there was no need by the highways for
any improvements to that entrance for
the 400 houses they felt that the
because it was used I think by
commercial use and pop concerts and
whatever now of course we've got all
this extra work to be done all put in a
cost on this on the site which in my
eyes is part of the reason that we
haven't got the affordable homes we need
we weren't hadn't got any at all then
the government gave some money and
they've used that to get it to 17-hour
percent far as I'm concerned that's not
suitable if you go up the road to me and
Vale they've got a brownfield site
they've got asbestos
they've got concrete's they've got an
old army camp they've managed 33.4%
affordable homes and mark here will tell
you as he did an application for 500
houses and I said I'm only concerned
about the road he said you can't talk
about that councillor bond because
that's in the outline I said my concern
was only two windows now they got the
max right they've got the affordable
homes at 33.4%
they've got the open spaces and on a
filthy site if you want to put it that
way
there was Ash came from there so in that
respect it can be done there were a
number of other points that I did want
to bring up in the respect of the mix is
obviously not right all the way down the
one side if you look in my eyes looked
plain there's been no discussion with
the developer whatsoever I went to a
meeting on Monday because the parish
council did manage to get them there
last Monday I was obviously advised not
to speak but to listen and and I was a
presentation to be honest
as far as I'm concerned it should be
refused on the reasons that are given
and also the police believe that Mike
gives a figure of 16 accidents in 15
years when we went to the police they
said 33 now in the process of improving
the road the garden center were supposed
to have a right-hand turn we have
negotiated that with a garden center
nothing to do with Carla but that will
be going in between the spring Christmas
rush in the spring rush if you see what
I mean
so as far as I'm concerned the other
thing that was said was that I asked if
the green 20 acres or whatever was going
to be on reclaimed land I don't know now
the reclaimed land part of the bad part
of may and Vale has all got grass on it
all got trees except now the County
Council can you believe it want them to
take the trees down because there are
traffic they could cause us get it now
as far as I'm concerned you've got a
site only two miles up the road which
was on a ground field site which I
believe if you like with negotiations
and hard work between the parishes and
the district councillors has come good
or is coming good although we're not
happy with the road infrastructure
that's been put forward
I appreciate though I'm coming to the
end of my turn I'm sure there's many
other things that I would have liked you
said but the point really is that this
is a one site for 400 not a garden
village maybe later but the point is we
can do a lot better than they have okay
thank you any questions thank you
capsule bonds can I ask you mentioned
you were at the parish council meeting
recently what level of engagement was
that between the developer and the
parish council up to this point
apart from that presentation at the last
parish council meeting no we're advised
was a high level of public engagement
prior to this was that the only public
engaged
didn't tell you no Keith I'm sorry we
got from the police I think because
they've been a big help
okay any other questions no okay
Thank You Cassius it's gonna be a long
ish evening probably I want to go into
the questions now but we will have a
break I think sometime during technical
questions okay yes
Kasane yes chairman
I would like some information on the
community orchard right I know that's
been mentioned but I believe no I'm into
technical questions yes what I was going
to suggest actually counselor before we
get there is that we take these
questions in in an order to start with
of of areas of concern rather than
everybody asking a question about an
orchard a question about a road a
question about viability we go through
bit by bit and then if you've still got
a question left at the end of my list I
have a little list and then then when
asking this it's out sorry I'll just go
through my suggestion of what okay I'm
in your hands we asked about the
external roads first we then go on to
affordable housing and housing mix we
then go on to the community employment
area the sports pavilion area the
internal road layout parking the general
layer and design of buildings and of the
site in general and all the other
physical
features and landscaping and drainage
then we go under the s100 sixes and the
trigger points for the various other
applications that are in there such as
health education the pavilion the
community area we so counselor we're
fully aware there is a significant
amount of this information on blue paper
which all relates to the viability and
the housing makes mix it would seem
appropriate I would think if we dealt
with that at the end once if we're not
allowed to discuss that in front of the
public
okay okay I'll take that I can drop that
off at the end if however any of the
other things touch on it we can do it
I'm hoping from what Rosa said that
actually we can do a lot about viability
and housing mix without mentioning
specific figures we can talk about
general principles so but if you want to
mention specific figures yes we will
have to ask the public to leave the room
so there's an explanation at some point
during these discussions we may have to
clear the room so that we can talk about
commercially sensitive information I
hope we don't have to but if we do
you'll understand why so are there any
I'll start off with external roads that
the Camden Road essentially plus the
entrance island and fresh fields nursery
site now my main concern here is that
the fresh fields nursery the site I
understand it's a matter which went
along with the outline application I
also understand that it has to be
resolved before first occupation I think
on this new site but I would like to
know this seems to be a little problem
with residents and they're thinking
about what is being proposed so thank
you you are correct
the outline permission there was a
condition which is condition
25 sorry condition 26 which required the
applicant to submit detailed design of a
junction improvement scheme for the
Camden Road Rash field nurseries access
that's a good idea if we can get a
Google image if I'll just continue
summarizing the condition
there was an indicative drawing that was
provided by the applicants to support
that outline application however the
County Council at the time didn't feel
that it was suitable so we worded the
condition that an alternative scheme
could be identified and designed and
come forward
Karla at the moment with their technical
consultants commonly in that process to
resolve condition 26 with the Highway
Authority
but also with Warwickshire police and
we've been having regular meetings at
which the ward members and County
members have been invited and attended
to provide their input on behalf of the
local residents we just in terms of
where we are we have a look we have a
drawing that has been submitted which is
currently being considered by the Road
Safety Team and comments should be
provided back to Stratford district
council shortly on that and just to make
sure what or another it has to be
resolved before first occupation it has
to be implemented before first
occupation of that of that of the 400
okay forgot anything else on the roads
the access tents of fielding I am
concerned as a gas main that is coming
down in formed earlier on along almost
the line of the road which has caused
the setback of that roundabout I don't
if that is the case but also there is
another gas main that is running the
other side of the site it's a little
more detail of that as it affects
society
mr. chairman do you want to pick up on
I've been asked to show where Clifford
Chambers is in relation to this shall we
do that now as I've body del okay
I hope that's clear to everyone up there
the site is it the bottom there where
the cursor is roughly in that location
there hopefully you can see the Camden
Road running northwards for two to three
miles
Clifford chambers is there I can zoom in
yep I was even at that level just so you
can see where Stratford was which is
just up here I further mile or so to the
north of Clifford Chambers so zooming in
you'll see it's in the area where the
Clifford Road crosses the River Stour
and it's this area here that we've been
talking about okay thanks that is a
reserved mater Freshfields nursery it's
it's in here somewhere I think isn't it
there we are okay
a gas main correct nursery school yep in
relation to the gas main we are aware
that there potentially will be utility
works along the Camden Road corridor but
obviously this will have to be reviewed
and given a license and booked in with
the County Council Highways team so that
have to go through the process in
relation to the orientation the
roundabout it has nothing to do with the
gas main the orientation of the
roundabout is due to that we are
changing the nature of the Camden Road
at the moment it's a high-speed route
with the airfield with no active
frontage along it and no residential
communities at that location to start ,
dating a residential community you've
got to start changing the character of
the road so the introduction of a
roundabout as with me on Vail was to try
and control speeds along the Camden Road
at that location so by bringing it into
the site we're creating a deflection of
the road which causes
vehicles to be deflected to slow down
and utilize a roundabout
if we kept it straight we won't get
enough reduction in the speed to to
safely
have a junction of that location and
therefore the highway authority
conditioned the access arrangements and
have worked with the applicants to come
up with a alternative solution the what
is proposed in the reserve matters is
the principle of the roundabout junction
which we have accepted but they still
have a condition to discharge on the
outline regarding that and it's going
through technical approval with the
County Council's
highways design team as well under
Section two seven eight of the highways
Act okay counselor building it's talking
the papers of a caravan site which I
believe is on the other side of the road
is that roundabout going to connect into
the caravan site the the caravan site
opposite is we are aware as the Highway
Authority and our are the applicants and
their consultants and it does have an
extant permission for their access
engagement so the applicants have to
include that access arrangements and the
lay-by the existing lay-by within the
roundabout remit to make sure that they
both function fully into account with
the accommodation of the development
okay so if we can we're going to do I
have some questions about the community
and employment area in the outline it
was much larger than it is now so some
comments about that briefly more
importantly because I think I understand
that I am concerned about how we
condition this and the trigger point we
we we bring this in it because if we're
only building four hundred houses and
we're triggering this at 350 and we're
triggering other things at 350 the the
amount of excess investment towards the
very end of the development probably
won't actually cover you know it won't
be paid for by the by the extra houses
so I'm just concerned about how likely
it is to happen I want to make sure it
does happen Thank You chair um in
respect of the the phasing of the sights
we are having ongoing discussions with
with Karla and one of the one of the
reasons why there is ongoing is because
of establishing trigger points for the
for the community hub I think in the in
the discussions that we that we have had
and the discussions that Karla have had
with with with potential occupiers I
think that there is an understanding
that at this time the saw uses which
will be occupying that will need a
quantum of development on there to be
attractive for example and that quantum
of development is probably going to be
the latter part of the of the
development now can I jump in there yeah
I can understand that yes yeah no one's
going to take a shop on or whatever when
there's any you know it's not going to
work you're gonna need the full four
hundred really for it to have a chance
of working frankly as a little but what
about building it at an earlier stage
yeah well what what this saw the tone of
the discussions that we have had has
been looking at getting a marketing
strategy early on a lot earlier on in
the process to establish whether there
is that need for at that time and that
will have to be continually updated and
reported to the district health these
are these are discussions like a moment
and if it was showing that there was a
need in a demand for it earlier on then
it could be brought forward what I'm
saying is I that's great and those
discussions are great but can we not
build it somewhat earlier in the phasing
even though we're not intending to fill
it till later on because presume
it's been modeled that whatever goes
there will work when you have the full
400 so you could build it six months
earlier you obviously can't build it too
earlier but you can build it at say I
don't know where your point was going to
be but you could build it at 250 rather
than 300 occupy it until 300 350 yeah I
take that the point that you're making I
think a lot of it is to do with exactly
what uses will go in there which we
don't know at the moment we've got that
that's just indicative as I as I sort of
laid out so a lot of what what you will
go in there what determines it will be
the marketing and the work which is
which is undertaken and that in a way
will then help to influence and sets or
trigger points as well and that's what
we're currently doing at the moment is
trying to get a phasing plan together
that will encapsulate these sort of
elements okay thank you cash a kettle
well on the same topic but looking at
sports povich's
speeches and sports pitches and
pavilions assuming that when the first
batch of houses is put on the market and
bought that there will be residents
children teenagers who want to use of
sports pictures and if you have got a
blank space that's sort of a terribly
desirable and therefore either you know
not providing those facilities to early
residents is going to leave early
residents without access to public open
space you've got running tracks which
you talked to me about the other day and
therefore I would think it's incumbent
upon us as an authority to make sure
that maybe not after the first 10 or 20
but those facilities which not have an
immediate commercial or climate of
having 400 houses to make them work but
actually those facilities should be
provided
in the early stage to ensure those
residents do have access to them because
some of them will definitely not be able
to be done because you're still building
out that far corner and therefore there
should be a time scale that says those
which are not dependent on a commercial
profit being made should be put in at a
very early stage in terms of the the
sports facilities that it's probably
best to solve them sort of split them if
you like in terms of the the southern
sports pitch is that that is separate
that is subject to a separate condition
where there is to be a time scale for
the for the delivery so so that will be
based on on discussions in respect of
the pavilion there is a trigger for the
350 dwellings and that is as there is a
viability issue within the scheme about
providing that earlier now I've had
discussions with sports England in
respect of that and I think given the
viability issues and given the fact that
there are some sports facilities nearby
that can be used in the meantime in me
on Vale for example and how we would
look to facilitate the use of those
would be bringing forward say the link
through to the Greenway to facilitate
the increase and better connections to
that I think in in the meantime prior to
a pavilion being provided there would be
sports facilities in the near
environment for residents to use so I
think we can we can factor that all in
and provide a comprehensive I'd a
phasing plan which will allow the
residents that come onto the site to use
facilities on-site as early as possible
but in the meantime facilitate the use
of the nearby facilities if that makes
sense so there wouldn't be a gap within
their ability to use some some sports
facilities in the immediate environment
and data
me unveil counselor what is the distance
between in terms of in terms of getting
down to me or Val we would look to get
the look to work with Carl it's getting
the phasing of the link through to the
Greenway then that would provide a
pedestrian cycle way down to those
facilities there is a direct link does
he can answer that one a distance it's
probably best counselor if we we get the
the map up again we can show you the the
distance
okay so the site before you tonight is
is in this area there may on violent
facilities there I would judge that to
be slightly under a mile as the crow
flies but obviously the Greenway doesn't
show that well on here you'd have to go
a little bit west I'm not entirely sure
how far they've got up me and Vale in
terms of providing a link through here
an off-road link but it last time I was
down there it was largely completed so
it's it's you couldn't go direct but I
would say it's just over a mile but it's
okay that's good
I'm counselor Caitlin's point about
having leisure facilities triggered
earlier on because of residents moving
in if you look it separately from the
sports pavilion which would occur a
greater cost at what point will the
sports pitches which I understand aren't
going to be floodlit to the ones we
discussed in the briefing yesterday
which were just simple kick around
pitches when will they be triggered well
again what I would refer to you to do
counselor is condition let me just see
which one is condition nine so that that
requires specifications to be submitted
and a program of delivery and it
probably the important pioneers
following consultation with sports
England so we would be raising with
sports England in terms of a timescale
and and specifications for the pitches
and based on that then we I can't answer
your question don't hate me now
but because it's conditioned but that
will be finalized via further talks
basically
so I knew you can't ask the question
directly now but just picking up on
councillor kettles point about there
being facilities close by that aren't
indirectly more than a mile to get to if
you're letting over seven or eight your
game plan and no that's not a planning
issue but just thinking about when you
are liaison the sports England is it
possible to emphasize that it would be
preferable that was earlier on in the
development rather than the 350 because
communities are set up quite early on
with smaller numbers yes I mean in terms
of the 350 that that's in respect of the
of the sports pavilion and that that is
that is a separate condition I can
assure all members here that the
discussions that I've been engaged in
with with car in terms of the phasing
have involved getting as much of the
community facilities open space as early
in the process as is as is possible
there is an issue when you're building
out a site of course in respect of
health and safety and how people can
actually move around the site there's a
set there's a separate condition about
construction management plan but that
also has to be taken into account
in respect to the provision of these
facilities so the simple answer is
absolutely he will member saying and
there are points which you would being
raised with Carla at this point in time
to be honest and they are partly ongoing
discussions going back to your
discussions then with colour on that how
close are they to what you're requesting
with that timeline well I think in terms
of purely the phasing plan I don't think
they're where there's an awful lot
between us to be honest I think it's
more the sort of trigger points what
makes it slightly more complicated
there's trigger points in the section
106 about the provision of open space as
well for example so you have to make
sure that they're aligned but in terms
of the work we're doing we have done a
lot of work with with Carla and that
will be continuing just before I go to
John and Chris so in general regardless
of the trigger points
all these facilities were looking at the
community hubs the employment and
community hub the sports field and the
pavilion will be delivered at some point
are we confident that we can secure that
under all circumstances or have
something to compensate for it I don't
want to compensate for it I want to
actually have it so I want to be really
secure that we get what's on the plan
there what we've looked at today I I
don't think we need any saw anything to
compensate for it that the discussions
which which I have had with Karla I'm
confident that it that it will all be
delivered what we are working on at the
moment is the trigger points and
ensuring that it comes forward in a
managed and comprehensive way that both
Karla and the District Council can work
with our catch so go ahead okay Mike my
comment is I think that it's badly
designed in on the grounds that I think
putting allotments bang next door to
sports facilities are wrong where they
could be much better used for bowling or
for tennis courts there's plenty of
space to the north of the site around
the orchard where one could put in
allotments which would then be part and
parcel with the the orchards and
everything else I think we ought to
insist in my humble opinion that we move
the allotments to a more appropriate
place so what's the most comment on that
um I think
I think as officers and and with Karla
we've worked hard on the layout of the
of the application and in terms of the
facilities to make sure a a significant
amount is provided and also in a
location which is reachable if you like
by by the the resonance of the site and
I think the way it's it's it's sort of
laid out with with facilities to the
north and south of the site within easy
walking distance and also where there's
obviously there would be sort of joint
trips with to the north the adjoining
destination play area and to the south
with the sports pitches as officers I
think we feel that that's an appropriate
layer and accepts that the reason that
because the the largest-scale site is
going to be right up against that that
are preventing putting in the allotments
there are ways you get to effect
building on that area that's going to be
fenced off to the north
well I think I think this area which is
not part of the it's within the red line
but it's not part of the current
application and doesn't make up part of
the 21 hectares that that is an
integration area if the 3100 does come
forward that that is true but I think as
officers in terms of the location within
this standalone application that I think
the location of the allotments has seen
it seen any project we've got that
councillor kettle term that we're
talking about sports pictures about the
internal layout the one of the things
you have with a sports picture if it's a
proper sellable pictures you have
coaches bringing
opposing teams I'm gonna the conference
been made in your report mail that
opposing people will be able to access
the areas however if you've got if
you've got there is no to take that
volume that size of vehicle and I think
that is something which gives me a
concern because where do you stick so we
get a comment on that okay when we have
to consider open space in terms of
highway terms we do look at it in terms
of children playing football and those
tournaments that do happen however we
don't see for Malick's means we don't
see a large number of coaches arrive and
we will generally see one and otherwise
we also see are there were small Binney
minibus or parents actually dropping off
and providing them it's a bit of a
mixture the site has been tracked to
accommodate a standard bus which is a
standard bus for stagecoach or
Johnston's that can access the site in
terms of the spine road and then there
will be walking connectivity down to
that area it wouldn't necessarily be
requirement for the coach to actually
get into that into that facility as we
acquire in Highway Authority
and it could then leave the site and
doesn't SOT uni remain to be parked up
it's a little bit of a it's a bit of a
difficult one because it's just
something that will naturally happen as
I mean the Highway Authority can't
control physically but I appreciate your
concerns councilor in terms of parking
provision so I think that's something
you need to consider yourselves as
counselors when you're making your
decision whether that needs more
specification and clarity and three
conditions counselor and that probably
reflects the county position I'm talking
about for the resident residents and the
opponents point of view the normal
procedure when the usage at schools with
I think is the coach pulls up parks
there the driver may be the coach she
doesn't want to have to head off the
strap for the game parking a large coke
pot somewhere and therefore it's not a
highways related question it's a design
of the facility issue well you don't
have a comment from our planning team on
that
so just to pick up on that point this 38
car parking space is there practically
speaking in the venture allottee that
the teams are coming by coach there
would be a lot less cars come into the
site naturally and it seems to me that
in practical terms the coach could
straddle some of the car parking bays in
that instance because there's a fairly
generous area of tarmac there that it
could use in those circumstances I'd
struggle to see the scenario where you
get three coaches and the 38 car parking
and spaces in full use given that
there's only three sports pitches any
that's good good reply any comments on
that we'll move on anyone else so if we
we've touched on parking so if we go on
to the internal road layout and the
parking specifically for the residents
and visitors has anyone gotten anything
on that councillor Cargill thank you
I suppose one of the first things we
should pick up on is the the trees down
the rule of art I'll use that word and
the fact that obviously we have had
issues in the past near here you guy was
putting treason and the difficulties I
assume that you're quite happy with the
trees and they're not going to be ripped
out in a few years time
because of visibility issues hi just a
couple of points on this one obviously
you mentioned parking road with I think
I'm happy now with the road with the new
people you doing attract along that warm
and just briefly cycle routes and the
joining footpaths around that particular
element of it if you wouldn't mind Jenna
Thank You chair in regards to the trees
street trees on this development so me
and Fairland
and it's an example where it's a
historic scheme where we trees have been
implemented and tried to be retrofitted
within the luck within the lunch
within the road layout in terms of a
landscape planner and we appreciate that
hasn't worked as a County Council we've
done a lot of work in this area not only
with structure but also with wallet
district and rugby on this development
you will see on the main community spine
road that a lot of the houses which are
accessed off it a lot of private lives
and this is to try and stop direct
driveways on to the community spine road
which was one of the issues we had with
street trees because we had to protect
the pedestrian visibility displays and
then we were trying to fit in street
lighting alongside it which meant the
tree unfortunately was always a bit of
the victim in the situation because
lighting is highway safety requirement
as a visibilities place so we've worked
closely with Carla and through our
design guys that we recovered in
developing to try and come up with a
solution which protects as many of those
trees so we've come along with the
private drive arrangement which means
that and we have wider
verges as well than we're having on our
on our standard development because it's
a garden village and that was something
that came out the design elements with
homes England so I think I'm quite
comfortable as a higher authority to say
that we we're happy and comfortable with
the principle of the street tease but
there is always a caveat with me which
is that it does have to go through
technical approval under Section 30 of
the Highways Act and there might be some
amendments to their locations but we
will try and keep as much as we can
because obviously it is a garden village
cancel fielding I gather there is going
to be a bus route around the site is
there any indication of how many buses
per hour that is going to be going
through it or is that going to be going
to be one second or twice a day so the
developments located from the B 4-6-3 to
come to McCoy door and Johnson's are the
key operator along that corridor and
actually have a very good frequency of
services between they're also serving
down to honey borne and railway station
the plan is to provide at least in the
first instance at least or a half hourly
service half hourly service and it would
use a loop within the site that has been
designed in the foot in this first stage
discussions are obviously ongoing with
the bus operators with our public
transport team and the monies to enable
that to come forward or we're under the
section 106 agreement agreed in the
outline so if we can go back to council
cargle is something we miss sorry just
ilka describe the cycle routes on the
you're joining the the internal
footpaths as well as we're talking about
internal so there is I just so there is
a main cycle route going through the
site which will join up with the
Greenway and there is a pedestrian cycle
crossing proposed there now as part of
the outline permission there is a cycle
pedestrian foot way going down the
Camden Road and joining up just above
Quintin I think it's which is a national
cycle route 5 so there is in terms of
going through the sites joining up to
the Greenway which is a pedestrian cycle
way route so both west and easterly
there will be routes that can be joined
to so in that respect the site is well
well integrated and then that will allow
a designated
there will be that's conditioned to be
provided going down to Quinn's and
joining into a national cycle routes as
well okay can we move on to sort of the
design than the layered design of the
house is anything else the landscape
features the drainage councillor Saint
yes chairman I've noticed should we be
mindful to approve this that we're not
following the example of the Planning
Inspectorate in a lot of Appeal
decisions where the planning inspector
is allowed an application they have
referred to a long list of drawing
numbers which have been specifically
designed to guarantee that the layout of
housing that has been approved at the
reserve massive stage and is retained I
think we've got an answer probably to
that comment from our that would be
control page 46 condition one
it could be controlled through that
development in accordance with the
approved plans and that would be listed
all the approved plans on there so that
any development carried out would have
to be in accordance with that so that's
that's the ones that you would see
decisions well I comforted by that we
should but but equally well are we
seeing these plans tonight we've had
executive examples of houses with
weatherboard frontages for example but
but but not specific plans and specific
layouts in my perception okay yeah I
mean drawing such as the elevations that
you've seen they're not indicative now
what is proposed there's some elements
that are indicative and a nail has
picked up on those and highlighted that
but there's areas such as as the layout
the scale the elevations that we've
talked about on the roads
that's not indicative that's fixed and
the approved plans would fix that
just say they haven't registered with me
so sorry just to clarify the plans that
we're showing you all the plans that
would be approved we're showing you the
plans off the application yes are you
looking for specific housing types Chris
or I know the officers have by the
sounds of it as various as you imagine
an application this size that there's a
lot of plans and we've got access to all
of them tonight if there's any
particular areas you'd like to have a
look at but obviously we haven't turned
them all in the presentation in Turks in
the interests of Ben's extinct well move
up councillor fielding indicated that
none of the buildings would exceed in
exceed 11 metres in height the some of
these apartment blocks are they going to
be within that limit they are they are
councillor in fact only this week sought
clarification from Carla that that's the
case and they've confirmed that it is
I've I've looked at I've measured the
heights of those it's also important to
look at the levels as well and the
information that we've got and I've had
a look at that so I'm satisfied that
parameter plan will be met yeah
councillor kettle you know it's just
looking on the actual application form
following Council Saints question it is
normal I know this is a huge application
but it is normal to display the designs
front view side view etc of the
properties and they're not here so yeah
we did have a we did have a brief
glimpse at a few of them if you have
another on the application are not on
the application so therefore in looking
at you what were signing off on we
haven't got a definitive list of what
these properties should look like I've
got to say I've never seen that in a
report I've always seen the actual
design when we get
have always been on the website under
the application but they will have
Street View yeah I haven't looked at the
online g1a therefore you know there is a
lack of clarity okay I do not know I
think we're talking about the EE portal
right this is a document that's been on
the website so it's been available for
anyone with an interest in the
application wishing to make comments
you'll see it's a fairly lengthy
document 66 pages but just to give you a
flavor of what's in there those are the
detailed house types and we're obviously
happy to run through those with you if
the details is an issue that you want to
explore see it I can't actually say it
on the on the portal of the planning
portal it's not that I think this is a I
don't think we can I don't think it's
but it's important but for general
public interest and I think it's useful
for for officers to pick up this it
should be there we should we should find
out about this I don't think it's
relevant to our decision tonight it
concerns me you can't find them that
they would be listed under associated
documents and plans I'm not sure what
table you're looking at again we'll
we'll move on from this because it's not
relevant to the nice decision counts of
cargo did you have a question
nice thank you very much may I return to
my question earlier on of the applicants
about solar panels and charging points
and socially I thought the slightly
contradictory and perhaps you can they
inform me a little bit more obviously
they were suggesting that they don't put
solar panels in because they say that
it's the fabric of the building which is
that's the sane of the element of it and
yet on the other hand we're saying that
we don't have enough power for electric
vehicles and we're going to have 10%
afford
which is obviously slightly contradicted
to me there was different few to comment
on them particular point please yeah
every design solution that we deal with
has to be a balance of conflicting or
differing ways of delivering more
sustainable development eye development
that results in less carbon been putting
out atmosphere in effect and that's what
we strive to do
we've got policies on that and as the
applicant explained earlier that they
approach it from a fabric first point of
view so effectively dealing with the
source of the weather the greatest
carbon is created I threw the heating
system of the house that there's less
load on that because the houses are
better insulated therefore they've
offset the need for having solar panels
on there obviously you can always go
further that they think they could put
solar panels on the proposal before we
tonight doesn't include that but in
officer's opinion the balance of all the
measures put forward represents the
sustainable solution in terms of
lowering the carbon footprint of
dwellings so the metric is carbon
generation or savings as the case may be
not power generation yeah the the two
are obviously linked obviously if if you
if you were to put soda pounds on it
then that the load on that on the
electricity network would lower and
therefore that the carbon footprint
depending on how that electricity is
created is lessened cancelling of the
stone-faced buildings that we have in
the entrance dotted throughout the rest
of the scheme it's possible to do that
but as this nail has already described
this an approach has been taken to have
strong character areas and the risk is
if you start to pepper pop and through
the development you start to dilute that
that you're seeking to create and as was
pointed out earlier the frontage of the
development was very much one that
borrows from some of the stone that you
see in villages like Mickelson and
Elving turn further into the development
it's slightly more urban around those
small tight parks and that's a redbrick
area more typical of market towns like
Stratford and chips and and
what-have-you
so the answer is yes you could do it but
you'd run the risk of diluting that the
character areas to have been thought to
be produced okay then we move on to I
haven't gotten any questions actually
understood the s106 is and the trigger
points the trigger points have kind of
been gone into I'm content with the
offices to do with s1 or sixes but are
there any questions on that now one
thing which is mentioned by various
villages is something which isn't
mentioned in the report which is
something like a village traffic plan or
something to various parishes mentioned
you know there's no there's no plan to
deal with extra extra traffic due to
this development do we have a comment on
that because I'm assuming most parishes
and villages believe there will be a lot
of extra traffic this was heavily
discussed during the outline planning
permit planning application when we we
determined it before and the modeling
demonstrated that there wasn't a
substantial impact on the villages of
Welford in long master because the
traffic was facing onto the Camden Road
there was identification of the need for
upgrading of of the weight to those
roundabouts as you come in on seven
Meadows roundabouts and also towards the
clock contribution towards the crops and
bridge improvements scheme which was
being promoted by Bell Mian fail and the
Loxley fall development so and this
application but obviously under the
other two applications that as a matter
we're having to consider okay so it was
considered really under and
the online applications are I want to
before we get on to housing mix and
affordability I'm going to have a great
if that's okay for ten minutes is there
anything else any other matters
councillor coastal bonds not
unsurprising you to refer to back boxes
I know there is some permission for that
boxes could we just have a little
expansion on what to level of battle
bird boxes is being incorporated in the
in the housing I know you say there is
something that it's not quite specific
condition seven in the committee report
requires basically details of the
integrated brick bird boxes which is
what councillor Barnes referred to in
his in his response to be submitted
including the the dwellings where they
will be provided so effectively I
haven't got a number for you at the
moment it's what we will EA's with the
applicant in respect to that if the if
the permission is granted I would also
add that we would consult with the
county ecology service on that point to
take their views on how many bird boxes
yes chairman I'd like to ask my question
about the community orchard and how
large is it and and how would it be
managed
how would it form a community facility
in other words just to give you an idea
of the size of it council up I'll show
you it on the and the plan so that's the
the destination play area and the park
that I referred to earlier so the
community orchard is that corner area
there I haven't got a precise
measurement for you in terms of in terms
of size but hopefully
that will give you some some idea of the
size in comparison to the other the
other facilities in terms of management
that if I can refer to condition 15 that
is a detail to be decided with with
Karla and we will ensure that
effectively there is as much community
involvement which is the whole point of
having the community orchard in terms of
the management agreement I can't give
you any details over at the moment
because we haven't reached a conclusion
and respect of it there will be some
management arranged but there will be
yes okay anything else well that's the
slight booty I mean I can look at that
and think is that portrait a quarter of
an acre or is it larger oh yeah we
should better have this actually because
quite frankly you know if we're going to
allocate it I want to see that we have
got a real community facility rather
than something that might sort of sit by
the wayside in the hands of a handful of
people
no I take your point counselor we have
work we have worked hard on that in
terms of the landscaping plans and the
landscaping and so on who's been working
on us has been looking at those plans
and Carl have reacted to comments in
terms of species and and what have you
in terms of the community orchard so
it's it's a lot more developed than that
plan perhaps shows so if I if that gives
you any comfort I hope it I hope it does
but again the condition will control the
management of that and I think between
the two the landscaping plans that we
that we've got and the management
arrangements I think I think that will
be a beneficial community facility okay
now I know we're gonna be looking a
break now and sorry for that you know
you might want us to carry on straight
at the nitty-gritty but and there is
something to be said for that to be
going into it while we're strong but
there's
also something to be said for being
fresh and not wanting to chuck it all in
so ten minutes okay back at 22 to go
into matters around affordability and
housing mix
lovely okay so we're going to go on to
portability viability housing mix
remember we may have to clear the room
for commercially sensitive information I
hope not I think we can do a lot of this
without going into financial details we
can think about principles and figures
of money and where they go I don't want
to have to clear the room if I don't
have to I can't really don't want to do
that so any question just counselor
cargo counselor cargo I will go back to
my previous question regarding the
obviously the I'm sure will be asked
questions about the housing element to
this sub-game a half percent as opposed
to thirty five percent which is our norm
and I appreciate that granted that
within that seventeen and a half percent
I'd like to understand why we haven't
got more social rented within that
element as opposed to the shared equity
which I know is a viable way of getting
affordable accommodation but it's not
the preferred way certainly not this
district and so I'd really appreciate a
little view as to why we've arrived
those particular figures I can give you
a relatively short answer and if you
want more detail I'm sure Anthony would
be able to help in terms of the social
rent
that's a greater cost of the developer
than the more intermediate ten years
because obviously social rent meets a
need in a in a greater way because it
takes people straight off the waiting
list so social rent is a greater cost to
the developer therefore if you increase
the amount of social rent in that in
that by portion you increase the costs
on the developer and that affects the
viability
so what you see proposed before you is a
balance of all those things and if you
move one thing around it has an impact
elsewhere but obviously it's just fuse
members to decide whether that balance
has been struck appropriately right okay
I do I do get that it's just the when
you say it's a cost to the developer now
the normal percentage for an market rent
is 20%
for example whereas these social housing
I correct me if I'm wrong is 6% is that
correct
the so closer could you clarify want
these percentage the profitability so I
didn't understand what you're talking
about okay
I think Richard does but it would be
nice if we all it's not as a planning
officer it's not my areas of expertise
I'm not a housing officer now we've
we've got Anthony here but I think maybe
John Cafferty's there is a head of
housing policy he may be able to shed a
bit of light okay John before you start
can you explain for the rest of us this
six percent 20% visitors as well and
then what you're going to comment on why
she chose the point was make use of the
there's different transfer values that
affordable housing provider will pay to
a developer for different ten years of
affordable housing
now that's linked to the the value of
that unit ie the amount of rent that the
affordable housing provider will then
get back over the lifetime of that
property from the tenants so for example
were an affordable rented product or
tenure that is say eighty percent of
market value will generate more ranks
over by the time than a social rented
product that is a fifty to sixty percent
the market value yes I understand how
nice if you want to answer the question
that looking for
and I thought okay that's the sort of
that's the moment and that is the the
yes the return on the property from the
developers point of view so do get
though think of M Cindy and that is why
we have arrived at the particular mix
that we're talking about obviously
Anthony from Colliers he has helped
officers to come to a negotiated scheme
with the developers he he's not the
gentleman who's negotiated it with the
developers so he's not in a position to
comment on that what you see before you
tonight is what in an officer's opinion
is an appropriate mix for this site of
all the different variables taking into
account all the other things we take
into account in the round okay thank you
very okay
councillor Perry Thank You chair can we
just have clarification on the
specification between the affordable
homes and the discounted tank are they
are they being built and designed to a
similar specification and is that pal
the 20% in the 6% differs in terms of
construction and layout and those kind
of things that they're designed so that
you wouldn't be able to tell the
difference obviously when it comes to
registered social and/or taking on there
may be differences too as you say the
fits out but but generally the aim is to
make sure if you're stood on the street
you wouldn't be able to tell which ones
will which but there are small giveaways
obviously in practice but but generally
there shouldn't be a difference are you
happy with that
cancer fielding there was an indication
that we are getting about thirteen
million or Carl are getting thirteen
million towards the development the
roundabout in other matters but there
was also comment about clawing back some
of that money if it wasn't all spent
surely that money should be the surplus
that goes into providing more the
viability case that's been put forward
takes into account that money if that
money were not secured for any reason
from Holmes England the viability case
would change considerably and there
would be considerably less scope for
affordable housing or whatever tenure on
this one so it's in the sums it's in in
Psalms that is the clawback issue is a
separate matter from that and that's not
what's been put forward well officers
aren't going to do do anything what we
would do is we have to respond as a
council to whatever Karla needed to do
in response to Holmes England not
funding them for whatever reason but I'm
confident that that will come to
fruition from the discussions and the
meetings that I've seen and heard with
Holmes England obviously being a garden
village it's very important that many
levels of government I'm confident that
that money will be forthcoming and
therefore that the viability scheme that
you see before we tonight he's on good
ground okay can i okay I'll let any
myself and then Chris come in it's just
just for clarification sewage do you
saying that this that I've ot study etc
and the amount of affordable housing
currently put forward is completely
reliant on the money coming forward how
what's it if that money doesn't come
forward then the amount of affordable
housing be even less than is proposed at
the moment as I say that I think it's
it's I'm highly confident that money
will come forward
knowing what I know however I have to be
honest with you if it were not to come
forward then the viability case would
change there's many other things that
could change a viability case that's
just one factor of many all sorts of
market forces could intervene so if
another viability case had to be put
forward in future who knows what may
change we can only make the decision
based on market factors and what have
you tonight
so there's Eva Marie if that happened
the planning application would come back
to us in a different form absolutely it
would be a materially different
application because it would have a
maturity different okay right clawback
was mentioned developers mentioned
something about they were kind of have a
clawback
deal with Holmes England I don't know
how that affects what I'm going to say
you might better tell me counselor
mosses point and other people's
everybody's point is we we would all
like to see if if there's a certain if
there's a more than expected level of
profit and we can and we can fix that at
our at Collier's estimate which is
probably higher than karla homes
estimate so that's fair to all parties
perfectly fair to Karla we have a higher
estimate of the profit they're going to
make they have a lower estimate the
profit they're going to make that seems
fair enough
if they make that high profit right okay
we're happy things stay as they are with
it but if they make you know 10 million
pounds 20 million pounds more whatever
it is you know on the sales of these 400
at the end at whatever point that is and
you've done the accounting and I'm sure
I can't you know I don't know it they
make 10 million pounds extra when
they've built out everything okay why
can we not have some of that to put
towards more social housing it just I
just do not see why we cannot do it
obviously officers have had lengthy
negotiations over many months with Karla
and we've explored all options the
application before you tonight doesn't
include a clawback arrangement that if
we have to determine what's in front of
you I've heard nothing from Karla to
suggest that they would agree to that so
you would need to members would need to
decide whether what's in front of them
is acceptable without the clawback
arrangement in the absence ability we
cannot put a clawback arrangement and at
this state you legally you could in
terms of tonight's committee but then
you'd have to consider the likelihood of
whether Karla would sign the 106
agreement in respect to that given that
they haven't agreed to that at this
stage and your opinion on that I
couldn't speak on behalf of Karla coming
us why we haven't put it a clawback
mechanism in there because Karla haven't
been agreeable to that that's not the
proposal in front of us that's a good
enough answer Thank You counselor kettle
did you say that the one is that hasn't
been signed the 106 agreement yeah what
stick the recommendation of the
recommendation is subject to the signing
of 106 agreement which it'll obviously
require Karla's signature well and if
it's got elements in there that they've
not agreed to as a risk it won't get
signed thank you sorry counselor
Katherine Toronto right Thank You mr.
chairman I'll try to make this as simple
or as brief as possible what we have
heard is from the first speak on behalf
the developer is that the problem with
the site is it is in bearing the costs
so sec [ __ ] the significant amount of
the infrastructure for the whole site
and i made the point earlier on that was
a lot of mechanism whereby the cost
could be properly attributed one
400 houses proportion to this site of
the 3102 future application and we were
told it's at between two different
companies and therefore that made it
impossible that I do have a major
dispute with him we'll come at that at
the debate but Richard said earlier on
that the viability study was a sound
basis to go forward were you aware that
this viability study on the blue paper
did carry a significant part of the
works relating to another application
yes as I understand it the costs in the
viability report viability report
reflect the higher levels the Vince
infrastructure then you would normally
find on a development at this so it
doesn't take into account future
development did we therefore instruct
Collier's and perhaps colleagues might
know to answer this did you can't carry
out any sensitivity on the viability
study to look at what the return would
be on a pro rata basis and it's not an
easy job I accept that but this is a
very large application on which a huge
amount of time has been spent by an
awful lot of people but you are
according to a CV or the company CV a
very very experienced company in
relating the viability studies was it
explained to you that the infrastructure
costs related to more than just the 400
home proportion of this overall site if
I could also add to that there's a
reason for that and the reason being
it's perhaps appropriate now to clarify
that the appears to be two types of
clawback being spoken about tonight and
I just want to clarify and I'm sure
roster which I'm not telling that all
that but it's you can come back she'll
call back well okay so Connors have not
considered what we've just heard it's
got colleagues have not considered what
the
real cost of the pro rata
when I say pro rata ladies and gentlemen
I mean the proportion that should be
attributed to this development as
opposed to the three and a half thousand
site now if we consider that this is
four hundred out of three and a half
it's not quite a tenth of it it's
slightly off attendance because for
originated question yes I'll get that
what would be the impact on your
viability if the infrastructure costs to
which we are referring which I think
I've picked up from here
we're reduced by 90% would that have an
impact on your viability report well of
course it would but 90% is probably not
an accurate figure the information that
I'm provided with I have to use when I
undertake my viability my opinion of
whether the the construction costs are
correct or not or whether they're for
this site or another site we asked
hundreds of questions on your going
through that process these are the costs
that are attributable to this
development the fact they are also
enabling for the next part of the
development is there but it would not we
could undertake the sensitivity analysis
to do so but it would not be appropriate
in my view
why not because actually what you're
doing is you're suppressing the
profitability of the first 400 by
incurring costs which don't relate those
four yeah I think the why not question
is and therefore boosting the profits of
the script if we can have Richard come
in first
I'm probably best based on sir that
because obviously we issued instructions
to Collier's and the reason for that is
and it relates to what I was saying
earlier about understanding the
difference in the clawbacks
the clawback that you're talking about
is a clawback
on another site in effect another red
line
the claw bat that this council uses and
has used on other sites is a clawback on
the redline site if it proves more
profitable than has been shown by the
viability report the reason that we
didn't instruct Kali is on that basis is
because I'm Ross will correct me if I'm
wrong there's no legal basis for clawing
back any profit on a future site rather
than the site that's actually under
consideration for that 106 can I jump in
there because I think the quest the nub
of the question is why haven't we split
the costs why haven't we asked them to
pro writer it to say right it's costing
you this you know why haven't we pro
righted it for that you know and said
right we're going to include the cost of
this island for instance 50 percent of
it in the next application is that what
you're saying Chris it is but my
question going on to college I'm sorry
for further your corporate name which is
probably appropriate it's your call it
is report not yours
would the housing mix affordability in
terms of affordable homes and the
housing mix change significantly if you
were to reduce and I accept 90 percent
might be a finger in the air a job
apologize for that but I'm just doing it
on housing numbers on a pro-rata between
one another
would that have a significant have a
significant impact on the on the ability
to deliver affordable homes and housing
which is more compliant with our policy
whether it's significant I couldn't
answer here today it would certainly
have an effect any variable any variable
input into the viability that we do is
going to have an effect if you assume
the growth is going to be slightly
different if you assume construction
costs are going to be this than the
other I'd go back to what I was saying
earlier I am provided with a cost plan
by the developer and I look at that cost
and I used that data in the appraisal
that I undertake I was not aware that
the cost plan for this application
included costs for other application for
future phases
I made the phrase a moment ago that I
didn't think it would be appropriate to
go and look at that why do I say that
because if the proper costs of enabling
the overall development by putting in
the correct pipes etc etc for utilities
the extra on costs of having to go and
retrofit that in the future would be
significant using your words and
probably much more significant and have
a detrimental effect upon future phases
if they won't put in now so it is a
proper cost to the development I've used
the cost plans I've been given we've
undertaken sensitivity on construction
on absorption rate which is the rate
that you sell the units on everything
else as well but in answer to a question
if if there was an element of the cost
plan that wasn't in this yes it would
have an effect right no counselor there
will be other questions but I do want to
stop on on the pro rata now I think
we've had enough on pro rata I don't
want to go any more on pro rata okay
did you as part of your process or I
mean I don't if I'm allowed to give the
quantum of the figure but can I give the
quantum of it you can't give build costs
acquisition costs like this is the
infrastructure cost which is in the blue
paper infrastructure costs no thank you
we will come back to them later but we
both know what the figure is did you
carry out in the audit process to verify
what was in that figure that was not
part of our instructions no I do want to
make a comment on that I'm not quite
sure what's being asked so maybe you
could
no sorry oh if you could repeat the
question okay I'll have another go in
looking through those figures it's quite
easy to get comparable figures for
selling prices for bill cost prices
legal fees agents fees professional fees
except for etc whereby you can compare
what is being put through the viability
study with other viability studies that
we may have seen or general market
information that is publicly available
information the bit that is unique about
this site is the infrastructure costs
which are special to this site either
because they are relating to common 8
contamination that may not exist
anywhere else all murrelet all may
relators are the ground conditions which
just happened to be there it is a very
very significant part of the overall
cost structure that being presented to
us in the blue papers so what are you
asking the question is what I asked was
what verification work had been done to
identity confirm that those figures were
reasonable give him a huge quantum and I
think we've had the answer the answer
has when I say all do it that means
verification checking establishing from
fresh point of view that they're happy
with it and the answer is from Collier's
that they have not been asked to verify
the quantum great so can we have a
comment on that from our team it's not
something we would we do obviously as
you'll be aware of various viability as
various viability consultants to look at
viability cases that's not something
we'd normally ask them to look at to
benchmark against of the viability cases
so we haven't done on this occasion okay
and and that counsel fielding I'm
concerned that when we had our meeting
Wynn's Neyland that it was indicated
that the roundabout was enlarged for the
next freight phase it'swell was well
known that there were going to be three
thousand houses done on the side why
wasn't that indicated as part of the
background information for Colliers I
cannot just add to that I can understand
why utilities you know it might be done
now because it would actually take off
the viability for the for the future for
the future thing but not quite sure
about retrofitting islands and accesses
and if they would actually be needed you
could have a smaller access for this bit
and a bigger access for the for the more
northerly portion we've got Ben sim
coming in on that and then in terms of
the roundabout the whilst we could have
a smaller roundabout for the 400 ho
application at some point we would then
have to try and would have to replace
that roundabout with a large amount
about which means later worse but it's
also to do with the extent of the
highway bounty it's the developers
choice that they've done the roundabout
and take it into the site and it's been
audited on that slide so it's basically
what the developers are proposing in
terms of the roundabout and I'm guessing
that's what the infrastructure costs
have been based upon is to developers
proposal in terms of highways I'll leave
it with you the account the district
offices to come further but the county's
perspective Jon do you want anything
else on that it just says nice confused
it just seems to me that we knew that
this was going to be 3,000 pounds we
knew that this was going to be 400 homes
surely all the infrastructure they
because we talked about the sewer and
sewage treatment plant and everything
else is going to affect the whole site
should have been allowed for in the
viability study
I think we've gone there actually we've
gone there unless you can say anything
you why why we didn't in just going back
to the lair you talked about in planning
terms this doesn't prohibit the the rest
of the allocation in the core strategy
coming forward it doesn't mean it will
come forward it just means it's future
proofed in terms of the size of the
roundabout and the size of the roads for
future development to come forward so
essentially we should we've we've chosen
not doing not to not to split the costs
between this and a future thing this
this is carrying more cost because of
the future 3,100 so everything on this
has been designed over to
over-engineered for this scheme of 400
and there's a cost with that and that
that is one of the reasons that the
viability case is what it is in the
balance is struck within that okay does
that mean that we could then ask for a
clawback on the larger scheme when if it
goes forward and therefore it would be a
greater clawback taking into account
what's here the lot the larger scheme
isn't before us we're only dealing with
the four so we can't impose anything on
the larger scheme today so there's no
way to link the two we can't impose
controls or clawbacks on the larger
scheme which isn't in front of us today
I could catch the kettle
I just like to point a clarification
what colleagues have said is I was not
suggesting that one puts in a far
smaller scheme on the basis you can have
to take it all up and put it up and put
it in later on all I was talking about
was cost apportionment to the right area
and sorry I'm not trying to get I'm
trying not to be that don't ask that
question again but I think the the issue
is yes we acknowledge that doing
everything in bulk is cheaper but it's
whether it's fair for it all to be
carried here okay that's more argument
Council O'Donnell so we only allow two
reports in front of us this evening yet
were being told that facilities being
put in with regards to a future larger
site but we've already discussed that
things are uncertain with market forces
and various things how sure are we that
larger sites actually going to take
place if we you know we're planning
ahead but we don't have any certainty
it's actually going to happen in this
format and it's in the core strategy but
in this particular format yeah it's it's
an allocated site in the core strategy
and therefore in interests of good
planning
you wouldn't design a site like this
that would prohibit that coming forward
as I said I thought we can't make it
come forward but it can look to the
future to make sure that it we haven't
designed something into this game that
prohibits that coming forward right so
essentially we have got to judge what's
in front of us today for whatever
reasons it's you know it has differences
to it to what it would be if it was not
part of a greater scheme officers and
this council to this point have chosen
to take a certain attitude towards how
they assess things they've they've
worked with the developers to to get to
the point they are on affordable housing
and tenure mix and it's all linked it's
all about cost and viability I think
we've got enough from officers to go to
debates I will
okay I catch the kettle cook some
building right first fielding I'm just
wondering bearing in mind the matters to
do with ground rents are we going to be
are they going to be allowed to charge
ground rents on new sales because at the
end of the day there's been a lot of
negative 'no sand the press about it I
didn't understand a question but I don't
if the officers do ground rents are
included in the viability model for the
apartments only there's no state charge
in for the houses most of the debate all
the press about ground rents is not
really about this type of development
it's about single landlords in town
centers that rip off their tenants not a
managed 400 unit scheme like this thank
you for the question and the answer was
good thank you counsel kettle um I think
I would like to ask a question relating
to the blue papers I'm sorry but I think
I need to understand exactly make it a
good one because this is the last one
and then we're going to debate what is
the quantum of the figures that were
talking about in relation to
infrastructure costs I think I know what
the figure is but I think it's something
I want to ask
I can't ask it in public and never going
to ask it private you want us to clear
the whole room now okay right drive to
read this
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen you can
start leaving now I've got to read the
official thing and we'll call you back
in when we're ready which will be
shortly very shortly
exclusion of the public the Chairman to
move that pursuant to section of 100 a
package for of the Local Government Act
1972 as amended the public be excluded
from the remaining business of the
meeting in view as a fact that the
nature of the proceedings will be such
that if the public were present they
would likely be disclosure to them of
exempt information under paragraph 3 of
part 1 of schedule 12a to the said act
as amended
I'm trusting there are no further
questions we should go to debate any
anyone want to start
still on Chris Costa Perry
well it's nobody else wants to start the
debate
I shall I've been quite quiet up until
now listening to various arguments and
certain things strike me this is a very
you know unique application in front of
us I think you probably heard me talk
about it's one of 14 garden villages
that were announced January I think it's
a shame that the government hadn't sort
of thought about garden villages before
we actually put our call strategy to bed
because actually I am sure John care
furred and the whole planning team would
have come up with a a policy about
Garden Village sites but it would also
have they include included exceptions to
the rule now I know we are very fixed on
housing mix and I know we're very fixed
on affordable housing but we do have in
our core strategy exceptions to the rule
I think by the very length and the depth
and the thought and the diligence
approached by our planning officer team
trying to work with Carla the developer
they have been talking months and months
and months and I think at the end of the
day they are the experts they've tried
to look at various ways we first had the
situation where the affordable housing
came in at nor percent
yes it's they've they've we've now got
it at half of the affordable housing and
I do think this is an opportunity this
is about placemaking this is not another
400 home development this is a chance
for stratford-on-avon district to be
leaders in garden village design and I
think the whole fact of the scale and
size of the development the aesthetic
feel the entrance the gateway and yes
they are trying to future-proof it
anybody in the construction business and
I have had some extensive years working
with the major house builders I do
understand you have to plan for the
future we have a golden opportunity here
I know it doesn't sit comfortably with
the affordable housing mix all the mix
of our housing but I think we've got a
developer who's prepared to take it on
we have a situation where it's a
brownfield site and we can create
something there is a place for the
future is a place for the future of our
future generations and I think the
amount of effort and the the whole
diligence towards this site I'm in favor
of going with the officers
recommendation on this point thank you
on the affordable housing and I guess
our guests benefit the brief interlude
was about construction costs and
specifics on construction costs which is
why we had to to move people out of the
room it was actually a valid call Thank
You councillor kettle
I think our officers have tried their
best with good advice
we have our policy team our planning
team both on board saying this is the
best we can get in this circumstance and
I'm happy to go with with with
recommendation counselor Cargill Thank
You chairman well I do agree I've been
I've gone through this as I'm sure we
all have and in infinite detail on this
i've also places that the briefing we
had neil i asked him as many difficult
questions there as i have done tonight
if in fact more and I think that Neil
answered those very clearly now this
isn't an easy one of courses but we
never thought it was going to be a
simple one we knew that the contaminated
site and and everything goes on about it
but having now gone through all of the
notes especially the blue papers which I
would like to reiterate I've moved on
from there
we've moved on from those I also accept
that yes we'd love to have the this the
affordable housing mix but I think that
the officers and the portfolio holder
have moved mountains to get to where we
are today
on this particular point and I know
their time and effort they spent on it
is significant so I'm I'm pretty
grateful of all the effort they put into
it now is it perfect
no there's any application perfect now
we've got a 29 homes per hectare density
sire on the site which is quite low in
there's a rural at the site but there
should be that way
about 48 percent greenfield space on
this one as well I don't think we got
you know solar panels but that's another
story we'll have another day but the
reality is this is a good scheme and I'm
happy to support it thank you
I like your comment I'd like to just
make a note of that because somebody
raised it one of the parish councils
about a 20% and I don't know where they
got that figure from it might have been
in in the blue papers but as you say we
have come on from the blue papers with
negotiation councillor kettle I would
congratulate Neil
and at the team highways everybody this
is a very very attractive scheme the
only walked rounded on Monday it is a
very good use of what is currently a
very much a redundant site and we need
to deliver homes in this district
however we need to deliver the right
homes and this is a very large
application this is not one hundred and
fifty two hundred that were seeing
around the rest of the site we've had
pretty robust arguments about eighty
nine houses in my ward where the housing
mix was wrong and the argument was we've
got to get it right we can't keep on
having exceptions to the rule there has
been huge concern among all all of
neighboring parishes about the
affordable mix about the housing mix and
that is something that we need to take
on board we spent I don't know how many
million on our core strategy comes the
sample they're better than I will and we
came up after a very intensive
examination period with two policies and
I think in this case it is only about
those two policies the mix and the
affordable element and we have as one of
the villages responded something like
three and a half thousand people on our
affordable house waiting list we need to
consider all residents or existing
residents and those who want to live
here rather than primarily thinking
about be showcased development which we
can show off for the rest of the that
the UK I'm sorry and that's how I feel
about it it will be attractive Neil's
made sure it's attractive with of course
the support of Karla together they put
together something which is very good so
I worked in here only one today with and
and then this thing about the cost came
through and I'm going to go back to it
I'm sorry mr. chairman yes you need to
put in the right infrastructure if you
are doing a phase development it's
complete waste of time to have to dig
everything up and then re put it back in
again at double the size triple the size
because you're going to put bigger
things in but that doesn't mean that
this project and all we're talking all
the talk about this project delivery is
affordable homes and we've used a valid
viability statement to calculate what
that number should be now what mr. mr.
Collier do apologize again what mr.
Collier has said is he was not made
aware and did not audit the
extraordinary costs put in relating to
the overall site now it's very admit
there is an exercise that can be done
and it hasn't been which would attribute
the right costs what you would do for
the floor for 400 and the and the 3100
coming later on which may or may not
happen but if it doesn't happen you
wouldn't be putting in the
infrastructure that we're talking about
at this stage so there is an additional
cost burden on this and if you run those
numbers through a very simple
sensitivity and I know marks been
looking over my shoulder at sensitivity
and saying that's far too simple I quite
agree it is but I don't have access to
the quantum information all the time
available given I've given this earlier
on this week to actually carry out a
detailed exercise but in my professional
experience over my professional
experience for last 20 years has been
doing commercial viability bise's
planning models and I know you've got to
do your work and the fact is we haven't
done the work at this stage and we have
not had the foresight to strip out
excess infrastructure costs here that
shouldn't really be borne by this
because you wouldn't have done it if you
thought about 4 400 by themselves
okay counselor I can you wrap up because
I wanna make a final point and therefore
I believe that we should not going
forward at this stage I prefer to see a
deferral and I would like to see can we
look at these costs because as we said
when nobody else was here these costs
are huge they are a very very very
significant proportion therefore cost
concerned and I think to go forward and
deprive our people who need affordable
homes and those people who want to turn
three-bedroom houses because we can't
afford it when we've been told by mr.
Collier that we he has not taken into
account and was not informed that those
figures were his information actually
10k is in a position where we've been
given a report where he has not been
given the full picture
okay relying on that okay so are you
going for we're gonna have a few more no
no no do you want to defer well I'm
considering whether that might be an
option to go forward so that we look at
these costs and take the opportunity I'm
gonna listen to cancer field in first
I'm happy to go along with councillor
Perry I said I think it's a very
nice-looking site is it looks good and I
think it will do a lot for the district
however what I am concerned about
bearing in mind that we are only looking
at the 400 houses is what I've been
going on all evening is getting the
allotment with the orchard so you've got
a community area of basically gardening
orchards and everything else at one end
and then leaving that area available if
it's felt that other forms of activity
are needed once you've got an allotment
in place it is difficult under the
allotment act to go in and take a get
rid of it so I'm quite happy to go along
providing we could alter that okay deal
with what I'm saying
Thank You councillor st.
yes chairman I'm closer to councilor
kettle as argument than the others I
personally think that there's a lot of
issues concerning instructions that
effectively that could have been varied
there's a lot of uncertainty about
certain issues we'll argue that the
viability is an assessment and therefore
you're going to have uncertainties but
without breaching the regulations you
know the the blue paper certainly
clarify some of those points so
consequently I don't hold with this
argument but suddenly the 400 scheme
came along in 2014 and everything around
it has changed since then I don't follow
that argument at all because as I said
it was in October 2013 when the core
strategy development certainly changed
direction significant okay so we've got
to look at this as we see it today that
you know I know I'm looking at as we see
it today yeah but what I'm saying is
that what what that did was that
actually bought in he effectively five
different sites and we had a public
discussion about the people who heard
that Chris but where we're going make it
where are we going well we're going
quite simply along a route in my view
that suggests that that again is the
cause of certain uncertainties I think
the question was the larger scheme was
known about when the 400 was introduced
because the 400 scheme came in because
feasible so we do we did we could
actually approve that without a relief
road and the bigger scheme required a
relief road and that was the clear
criterion between the two schemes that
came about in core strategy development
at the time believe me I was involved
and I know about that and therefore I'd
appreciate it if you if you would say
that point very much on board I take you
but it's a moment
so many uncertainties that I feel that a
different set of modeling could come
forward which could give us a different
proportion the white papers admit on
page 39 that the proposed housing mix is
not in accordance with the preferred
housing mix or in core strategies CS 19
and that's a quite a clear statement in
the officers report to us tonight and
effectively I again I agree with
councilor kettle we can't keep saying oh
there's got to be an exception otherwise
we end up will end up with too many
houses in the district of the wrong size
and that's that's quite a question or
argument Chris and I think there was
that there was a question of a deferral
which I will ask for clarification on
well before we go to any I'm no porting
that kosair O'Donnell Thank You chair
cooing what calipari said I do think
this is a golden opportunity for
Stratford I really like the design it's
taken an awful lot of thought it's
future proofing its looking at both
physical and mental health and
well-being of the inhabitants I think
the offices have done a tremendous
amount of work to be congratulated on
that along with negotiations with our
portfolio holder and I can see a lot of
progress has been made however it
doesn't meet the criteria for the
housing mix that we need and that leaves
me with grave concerns because there is
not enough of the social housing mix
that we require and when they counts the
catalyst raise concerns over the
viability study I would be supporting
him in his request for deferral just to
see if there's any maneuvering or any
movement we can have on those on the
housing mix because all in all the
scheme is a really good scheme the
designs are great the layouts lovely but
it's just that that social housing
number okay
so better okay so just clarify something
okay it may be I don't know what the
exact reason for deferral might be but
the is a opportunity we've got Anthony
from Cali who's here tonight but he may
be able to provide more information on
that to avoid the deferral
well okay I doubt it I think we've gone
I think we've gone through that I think
we've gone through that
Cantus our kettle would you like to say
anything well looking at mr. Collier mr.
Collier it's a man Tony Shapland from
Colliers mr. Chaplin with shaking his
head when Richard suggested that it's
not an easy job just to change the one
of the basic costs and suddenly turn the
sausage machine or come up with an
alternative mix it's not something I
believe well you can try it mr. Chapman
if you like but I suspected be quite
challenging I my proposal I think you
were asking me to put more clarification
on it is in every other respect I
support this application except for the
mix issues both affordable and build mix
and it is entirely that those criteria
have been determined in front of us
today by mr. Chaplin and his team on the
basis of information that he was given
that we've subsequently he was not told
related to the whole site there will be
a mechanism particularly somebody as
well-informed as mr. Conn mr. Chapman is
and his firm Collins who will be able to
at least make a reasonable assumption as
to what the split should be between any
future development and what is directly
attributable unnecessary for this yes
there will be roadworks that will be
over over engineering at this stage but
there will also be work relating to that
the whole capacity which means none of
those costs will need to be incurred a
second time if another application comes
through and what we were not looking at
saying we wouldn't do that but what
we're saying is what is a fair
proportion of those costs and what
impact does that have on the housing mix
because the viability study all these
new papers all about driving down what
is the actual percentage splits
we've got Collins came out and said 20%
as a minimum and we're talking 17 a half
percent and now we find that colleagues
were not aware that that about say the
figure the figure that I referred to
earlier on in private session there's a
whole lot of extra stuff in there that
might not be necessarily related to this
project
therefore I'm suggesting that we should
give Colley as the opportunity in
consultation with officers and with the
developer and turn round and the say a
fair proportion of it would be this that
colors run their mission return the
sausage machine handle on their
spreadsheets which they've developed for
this site and say if that was the case
and the directly attributable costs were
reduced by whatever percent it is then
we can actually afford to squeeze out an
affordable house so what you're saying
is we would we cut that amount out of of
the bill cost and affiliate it to the
next stage
even though the next stage isn't built
right that's what we're saying and
therefore we run that we run the numbers
to see everybody squeeze up the
affordable number we've done this before
I'm gonna have a final comment from our
team on that and then we can you can
make a proposal if you want after then I
think it would be helpful if Antony
responded to some of the points that
council has raised because the may be
some level of misunderstanding I
appreciate it's a complex area and it'd
be useful to clarify it tonight if we
can I think yeah can I just ask why you
clarify that cap you know it's the
question of stripping these costs out
for future development and and where do
we get rid of those and how do we get
rid of those and can we
thank you
firstly in closed session you talked
about some figures I've found those
figures and I'd like to go back into
closed session and actually explain what
those figures are there's a figure
you're talking about is incorrect so I
would like to do that because I think as
you were saying that will help clarify
for the people that are in front of us
now exactly what the kind of proportions
that you're suggesting might come out of
this exercise every other before we do
that yeah every other answer that I
would have in response to what you're
saying would have to have numbers
involved which I know I'm not allowed to
do yeah so we've been here three and a
half hours so that's my fault we have to
vote if we want to carry on all those in
favor of carrying on and finishing thank
you now can I have that thing again up
but I'll ask everybody to leave again
for a few minutes
there's no teachers to say begin
percent I think chairman that the
question of the remediation costs was
understood from day one in my view and I
think the uncertainties come about
because we're trying to address figures
now on certain parameters and therefore
I would support a deferral for the
simple reason that there are issues to
regularize here okay are you suggesting
that i proposing a deferral i thought we
did anyway i did originally second it
but having heard the explanation nappin
Collier's i won't be asking for deferral
because he's explained the figures to us
so Chris can you make a proposal to
defer and cancel saint i think a second
- okay what why are we deferring we're
deferring on the basis that we need
further more detailed clarification on
what the correct gospel it some of those
items might be I accept information
we've heard from this Shapland in closed
session suggests the figures I was
talking about might have been overstated
in fact that he's convinced they are
overstated but given that we're talking
about percentage points in terms of
affordable delivery and that we are way
way way away from where we should be in
terms of our core strategy okay that
there might be incremental increases in
affordable delivery if there was to be a
finger in there which I'm not going to
do a code option all right so we've had
a proposal for deferral and we've had a
seconder for provoked deferral all those
in favor of a deferral - chairman all
those against for chairman great lovely
can we suppose
okay so we've got a proposal and a
seconder
to grant permission right all those in
favor of granting permission its we
chairman all those again excuse for for
what you saw
oh it's behind the screen for need to do
we're gonna do that again
yep all those in favor of granting for
chairman all of those against Sui
chairman okay this committee has
resolved to grant planning permission
17:03 to eight finally thank you very
much thank you very much on the agenda
yeah
we have no urgent business great